je vous propose qu'on y aille
mes chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs
nous poursuivons cet après-midi nous
travaux avec une table ronde
déterminante qui porte sur
l'accompagnement des élus dans leur
projet de rénovation ou de construction
du bâti scolaire notre objectif
aujourd'hui est de comprendre
dans ces dimensions très concrètes le
parcours des élus mettant en place un
projet de rénovation de la Bâtie
scolaire pour respecter les échéances
prescrites par le décret tertiaire et
optimiser leurs dépenses en énergie
certaines collectivités ne disposent pas
de services techniques suffisamment
étoffés pour les aider dans les
démarches diverses et complexes
qu'impliquent la réalisation de leur
projet leur accompagnement pour franchir
les étapes techniques juridiques et
financières de ces projets et donc
particulièrement important
nous accueillons ainsi au Sénat en
présentiel ou en visioconférence
la Fédération nationale des
collectivités constantes et régies FNCCR
représenté par monsieur Guillaume Perrin
il va arriver
coordinateur national du programme acté
action des collectivités territoriales
pour l'efficacité énergétique et
Monsieur Mathias Carteron chef de projet
bâti scolaire
en vision ils arrivent ils arrivent
aussi d'accord
de l'ADEME représenté par Monsieur
Christophe
le stage coordinateur conseiller en
énergie partagée du service des
politiques territoriales en visio
de la Fédération des agences locales de
l'énergie et du climat la flamme
représentée par Madame Maryse combe
présidente monsieur Rémy chabrila
président de la dune la lettre du puits
du Puy-de-Dôme et de Monsieur Franck
sentier délégué général qui sont en
visio
du cerema climat et territoire de demain
représentés par Monsieur Pascal Berthoud
directeur général
donc il est très bien représenté
la Fédération nationale des conseils
d'architecture d'urbanisme et de
l'environnement le cieux représenté par
Monsieur renaud-barrès directeur
du CAUE des Pyrénées-Atlantiques et
Madame et Léonore chambre à la Fuente
chargée de mission en visio également du
Centre Scientifique et Technique du
Bâtiment
représenté par Monsieur Julien Hans
directeur énergie environnement du
Centre Scientifique et Technique du
Bâtiment de Grenoble
en présentiel et de l'Institut français
pour la performance énergétique du
bâtiment
représentée par Monsieur
Christophe Rodriguez directeur général
et Madame Nathalie Ledermann responsable
projet
q-poice et cube.com avec un S
nous sommes intéressés par le programme
cube.s compte tenu de l'efficacité de la
sensibilisation des utilisateurs en
termes d'économies d'énergie de même
l'enjeu pédagogique que représente la
formation des jeunes aux questions
environnementales et pour nous apporte
l'existence d'un championnat d'économie
d'énergie ne pouvait comme vous
l'imaginez que nous intéresser je
précise également que nous allons
rencontrer que nous allons rencontrer au
visioconférence le CIAU de la Réunion et
que nous aurons l'occasion lors des
prochains déplacements de retrouver sur
le terrain certaines des structures que
vous représentez je pense notamment
aux Alecs je rappelle à votre à votre
attention Mesdames et Messieurs que
cette audition fait l'objet d'un
enregistrement vidéo qui sera disponible
sur le site du Sénat et qu'elle donnera
lieu à un compte rendu écrit qui sera
annexé à notre rapport
comme vous êtes nombreux autour de cette
table et en visioconférence parce que
autour de ces tables vous n'êtes pas si
nombreux que cela a tout dire je je vous
serai reconnaissant de bien vouloir
respecter le temps de parole 10 minutes
par structure à partager en cas
d'intervenants multiples
nous souhaitons en effet ménager à temps
des charges d'échanges après vos
différents exposés notre rapporteur
madame avait est empêché de participer à
cette réunion par un cas de force
majeure je vous prie de leur excusée
mais elle suit nous échange à distance
sur notre site
voici une précise que le règlement
du fonctionnement des missions ne permet
pas dès lors qu'il s'agit d'une mission
plénière comme c'est le cas cet
après-midi de d'intervenir à distance je
pense qu'on va solliciter qui de droit
pour voir comment on pourrait faire
évoluer ce règlement qui à mon avis
n'est plus vraiment adapté
voici les questions qu'elle souhaite
madame la rapporteur vous posez par mon
intermédiaire pour lancer nos débats
comme cela vous a été indiqué
précédemment cette réunion sera
articulée autour des questions suivantes
comment chacune des structures que vous
représentez conseille-elle les élus et
accompagnantes et accompagne-t-elle leur
projet
comment ces structures travaillent-elles
ensemble dans ce qui ressemble à
première vue à un maquis de guichets
différents
nous nous intéressons plus
particulièrement aux élus qui disposent
de peu d'ingénierie dans les services de
leur collectivité c'est la majorité des
collectivités néanmoins
comment réussir
comme réunissent-ils les expertises
techniques nécessaires à la
l'élaboration de leur stratégie
autre question comment sont-ils
conseillés dans les choix juridiques
qu'imposent tout marché public
puis deux questions en référence au
rapport de marque le rapport de marque
de 2020 sur la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments scolaires notez la profusion
de documents mis en ligne par divers
centres de ressources et plateformes
pour conseiller les élus on amant de
leur décision
ce rapport faisait également état de
l'impossibilité de dresser un inventaire
et ses guides qu'en pensez-vous quelles
sources d'informations conseillez-vous
aux élus pour conduire leur projet
le rapport de marque de 2020 appelé
aussi à une étroite coordination entre
dispositif des conseillers en énergie
partagée animée par l'ADEME et le
programme acté action des collectivités
territoriales pour l'efficacité
énergétique portée par la FNCCR je
souhaite est-il satisfait ou cette
recommandation est-elle toujours
d'actualité enfin
dernière question pour ce premier tour
de table j'ajoute que l'utilité des
économies des économes de flux ne semble
pas
approuver mais des élus auditionnés la
semaine dernière
témoigner de la difficulté de recruter
qu'en pensez-vous voilà je vais donner
successivement la parole en commençant
par l'ADEME et par Monsieur le Directeur
Général de la dame s'il veut bien ouvrir
les changes
attendez bien
oui très bien alors je précise tout de
suite je ne suis pas directeur général
de l'ADEME je suis simple ingénieur en
charge de l'animation du dispositif des
conseillers en énergie partagée donc le
dispositif CEP et viendra
dispositif CEP donc qui est le plus
ancien de tous les tous les réseaux de
conseillers en énergie partagée ou
économe de flux
alors c'est né en quelques mots d'une
initiative
territoriale alors ce n'est pas de
Moselle mais ça venait de Bretagne ou en
fait ils se sont demandés comment
accompagner les petites communes
sachant qu'ils avaient l'habitude
d'accompagner les grosses les grosses
communes de Bretagne et donc du coup ils
sont dit on va adapter un petit peu les
tous nos axes d'intervention
sachant que les que les petites communes
n'ont pas les moyens de recruter des
conseillers énergiques même s'ils
avaient des moyens cette situation ces
personnes-là seraient en situation
sous-emploi donc l'aîné l'idée est née
tout de suite de mutualiser des postes
au sein d'un territoire
sachant que là on s'adapte bien un tissu
souvent rural de petites communes donc
ils ont innové ils ont ils ont décidé de
créer quelque chose au niveau de leur de
la région Bretagne du coup comme ça a
plu il y a d'autres régions qui ont fait
la qui ont fait des choses à peu près
équivalentes avec des modalités des
appellations différentes il y a eu une
évaluation nationale et suite à cette
évaluation il était décidé de
nationaliser ces initiatives c'est comme
ça qui est né de les CEP donc c'est une
initiative terrain en fait qui a été
nationalisée donc ça a été nationalisé
il y a une dizaine d'années alors un cep
c'est quoi un cep c'est d'abord un terme
ici
un termeicien dont le poste est
mutualisé sur en général une vingtaine
de petites communes lors des communes
c'est en général 1800 habitants la
taille la taille moyenne
on est loin des métropoles
et comme vous savez les communes c'est
environ 15 bâtiments
ils font quoi ils font trois choses
alors ils font d'abord notamment les
premières années tout un travail un
petit peu de bilan diagnostic
donc un travail d'inventaire de
patrimoine souvent les communes elles
ont pas toujours connaissance de
l'ensemble de leur de leur patrimoine et
au-delà d'une simple liste il y a
également les les grands flux en terme
de consommation et les bidons
ça ça permet surtout quand on fait un
suivi de détecter des erreurs de
facturation
ce qui permet de faire tout de suite
l'optimisation de tarifaires des
préconisations hiérarchisées aussi
parce que du coup les les communes comme
elles ont pas cette compétence
l'économes de flux ou le CEP qui qui
vient leur fait des préconisations
hiérarchisées alors du coup les après
c'est les élus qui ont le la mer pour
reprendre ou pas l'initiative de de
réaliser des projets de de rénovation et
là le rôle des CEP va être d'accompagner
les élus alors que ce soit pour fournir
des conseils de type aide à la rédaction
de cahier des charges aide à la au choix
de la maîtrise d'oeuvre recherche des
aides mobilisables
alors c'est pas de la MO mais c'est
quand même de l'accompagnement de projet
et au-delà de cet accompagnement je
dirais en bilatérale il y a également
une animation qui est amorcée au niveau
du territoire qui peut être ambassé un
emploi qui peut être un département
qui peut être une communauté de communes
du coup sur ce territoire il va y avoir
des actions regroupées de type justement
achat à chaque Aubin mise en réseau de
des acteurs puisqu'ils se connaissent
pas entre eux toujours
information sensibilisation retour
d'expérience donc ça c'est la première
partie concernant un COP c'est quoi
[Musique]
je vous ferai grâce des chiffres vous
trouverez dans les rapports et on a
également des chiffres en termes de des
économies générées par un cep comme un
CP combien ça coûte combien ça rapporte
voilà donc ça on a des chiffres par
rapport à cela alors des CEP aujourd'hui
il y en a il y en a près de 400 ils sont
364 à ma dernière dernier mot recueil il
y a à peu près deux CEP par structure en
moyenne
dans ces structures ça peut être elles
sont représentées autour de la table ça
peut être des syndicats d'énergie ça
peut être des Alecs ça peut être des
EPCI ça peut être des territoires de
projet de type pays PNR
etc ça peut être j'en ai également dans
les CAE j'en ai quelques-uns on est dans
les départements
la répartition géographique il y en a à
peu près dans presque tous les
départements on retrouve une bonne
proportion en Bretagne puisqu'on partit
les premiers donc ils sont toujours les
ils sont toujours les premiers
alors nous l'ADEM qu'est-ce qu'on offre
on offre on fait quatre choses pour pour
piloter ce dispositif donc il y a du
financement dans la création de poste
donc on aide à la les trois premières
années de création de poste avec un
objectif de pérennisation
voilà donc après j'ai des chiffres
également combien ça coûte combien
combien on verse au-delà du financement
on verse et on propose également un
parcours de formation dédié pour les
conseillers avec différents modules qui
leur sont dédiés excusez-moi excusez-moi
de vous interrompre est-ce que vous
pouvez néanmoins donner quelques
chiffres combien ça coûte ça alors un
cep en fait le le poste c'est 100.000
euros par an 100.000 euros c'est salaire
chargé plus un bout de manager de secret
de secrétariat plus le bureau plus les
déplacements donc c'est 100000 euros
tout mouillé et nous on verse 100000
euros sur trois ans donc on verse à peu
près un tiers de
et on a un budget d'environ 3 millions
donc on a recrute on finance le
recrutement de 30 nouveaux conseillers
par an
voilà sur sur trois ans
parcours de formation donc on a on a six
modules dédiés l'outillage on a un
espace collaboratif avec deux trois
fonctions principales le forum pour que
les conseillers puissent échanger entre
eux on a l'agenda partagé il y en a un
répertoire partagé quand un nouveau CEP
arrive il a un répertoire avec plein de
choses à regarder et une série
d'animation avec des rencontres
annuelles des rencontres nationales
annuelles que l'on organise et notre
spécificité par rapport aux autres
acteurs je pense ou quoi que pas
toujours c'est également une
animation qui est régionalisée aussi
puisque l'ADEME ce que vous savez il y a
la moitié dans les services centraux et
la moitié sur au niveau des
implantations régionales
alors sur les 34 CEP on en a on en a une
petite dizaine qui ont des profils
atypiques dans le tertiaire on en a dans
le dans le secteur santé on en a un dans
les universités donc c'est pour ça que
je vais vous en parler aujourd'hui
puisque celui-là il est il est
doublement atypique il est université et
il est en plus outre-mer donc on en a 12
en outre-mer sur les 364 et donc vous le
verrez dans le dans le document pour que
j'ai il a fabriqué des générer des
écogestes des affiches des guides sur
les brasseurs d'air des vidéos donc il y
aura cinq vidéos sur la rénovation
énergétique avec des
que vous pourrez voir concernant la
climatisation la production solaire la
végétalisation etc
il me reste une petite minute ou deux je
sais plus là concernant
concernant carte alors les autres vont
également parler l'initiative carte
c'est pour répondre à votre question
concernant les synergies avec les autres
réseaux alors évidemment le premier
réseau que l'on pense c'est CEP économes
de flux puisque c'est les plus proches
cousins mais il y en a également
d'autres il y a également la santé et
l'enseignement supérieur donc
aujourd'hui on est quatre acteurs
engagés dans une dynamique carte c'est
un acronyme qui voilà
peut-être que demain il y en aura
d'autres qui viendront rejoindre cette
initiative je pense notamment à
l'immobilier de l'État ou les lycées les
collèges les casernes de pompiers etc
parce qu'en fait on a tous les mêmes
enjeux que ce soit les enjeux
réglementaires du décrétaire Sierre les
mêmes enjeux de difficultés
en termes d'emploi
on a
tous les conseillers ils ont des noms
différents et en fait ils sortent des
mêmes écoles donc en fait il y a
vraiment un enjeu de faire des choses en
commun alors du coup il y a déjà des
choses qui sont faites pour répondre à
Monsieur des marques qui est pas présent
priori donc la rencontre nationale
commune pour la première fois en 2022 on
a fait une rencontre nationale cepact
habituellement c'était que CEP donc en
2022 c'était COP et à l'automne 2023 on
va faire une rencontre nationale à 4
donc avec les deux autres réseaux que je
vous ai indiqué on a également comme
vocation de mettre en commun un
outillage notamment on va essayer de
créer une plateforme commune alors dès à
présent l'espace collaboratif des CEP
invite les autres les autres membres les
autres réseaux aujourd'hui il y a 400
CEP mais il y a 800 contacts dans
l'espace collaboratif COP avec 200
économes de flux actés et puis 60 santé
et demain on va également partager des
catalogues et trouver des synergies en
matière de formation voilà donc là c'est
un peu plus compliqué parce qu'il y a
quand même le recueil de l'écueil de de
l'argent là sur la partie de l'emploi
malheureusement on n'a pas avancé encore
ben voilà j'ai atteint les 10 minutes
bonne continuation
si j'ai néanmoins encore une question
vous disiez tout à l'heure que vous
étiez présent partout sur le territoire
mais y a-t-il des territoires qui sont
un peu en retard par rapport à la
moyenne
alors le des diffusions effectivement
c'est par région s'il y a la Bretagne
qui est en premier il y en a d'autres
qui sont un peu
le tour de tête mais toutes les régions
il y en a c'est plutôt dans quelques
départements et c'est plutôt département
alors je parlerai pas la diagonale du
vide mais il y a dû y avoir une dizaine
et on va retrouver
on va retrouver par exemple le Cantal
pour trouver la Haute-Vienne on va
retrouver la
ça va être la Somme
on vous a perdu
[Musique]
est-ce que vous nous entendez
oui nous avons été déconnectés
apparemment
d'accord
et
le monsieur le stage ce qui est toujours
là ou pas
[Musique]
je me suis reconnecté pour votre info on
a été coupé oui
du coup j'ai vous avez entendu ma
réponse ou pas
Haute-Vienne oui la Haute-Vienne et
après donc il y avait également l'Oise
et puis la Saône
actuellement la Corse alors que j'ai eu
un COP encore pendant pendant trois ans
actuellement il y en a plus il y en aura
à nouveau après la moitié de ces
départements où il y en a pas
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y en a eu hier
il y en aura demain grosso modo
globalement c'est qu'il y a une
couverture qui a été insuffisante au
global en fait il y a 8000 communes qui
sont aujourd'hui accompagnées par des
CEB
8000 ça fait à peu près un quart des
communes de
moins de 10 000 habitants donc c'est pas
rien un quart mais en même temps ça veut
dire qu'on ne couvre pas tout le
territoire
très bien et
merci et nos sales limites c'est le
budget et puis l'emploi voilà
les ressources je vous propose qu'on
poursuit avec le réseau flammes
je souhaiterais vous vous posez une
question depuis quand vous ne l'avez pas
précisé très exactement
ce dispositif est-il en place
concernant les CEP le dispositif a été
nationalisé en 2012 donc ça fait 10 ans
parce que bon j'ai pris une un
département pendant 6 ans et j'ai pas
jamais entendu parler de ce dispositif
bon
mon appartement
donc il faut améliorer la com sur le
reste donc on a le taux de couverture
nationale quand il y a un problème de
responsabilité
l'employeur et
la collectivité ou le PCI ou un CAE
quelconque
qui est responsable de ce personnel
c'est
l'employeur en titre ou est-ce qu'il y a
du côté de l'ADEME puisque ce sont des
gens que vous recrutez me semble-t-il si
j'ai bien compris est-ce que il y a une
convention de responsabilité s'il y a
des problèmes au niveau de la mise en
place par exemple d'un système de
chauffage ou autre
alors en fait c'est pas la c'est pas
l'ADEME
de responsabilité c'est le
responsabilité de l'employeur en fait
d'accord et puis dernier point quel a
été vous avez évoqué rapidement le sujet
tout à l'heure la pérennisation des
postes qui ont été ouverts et quel est
le taux de pérennisation de de ces de
ces postes
alors en fait les
j'ai pas le chiffre précis je dirais que
c'est aujourd'hui la grande majorité
notamment parce que on est plus sélectif
dans les dans les dossiers que l'on
finance
à partir du moment où on finance 3 ans
parce qu'on a une autre système bien qui
a évolué donc à partir du moment où là
ces trois insectes du coup pour
maximiser les probabilités de
pérennisation du coup on va se montrer
plus strict dans le choix des dossiers
et notamment les porteurs de projets qui
sont un peu plus un peu plus faibles on
va essayer d'améliorer ces projets pour
que ce soit sur un périmètre plus
économiquement plus rentable derrière
donc on a un très bon taux j'ai pas le
j'ai pas le chiffre là mais en fait
concrètement c'est un sujet que qui me
remonte jamais aux oreilles parce que
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas vraiment
le
sujet de préoccupation en fait alors
après à titre individuel en plus comme
il y a la question de l'emploi qui se
qui se pose donc un cep il y a du qui va
partir d'une structure il aura beaucoup
de d'offres d'emploi qui vont lui être
proposés voilà
très bien donc je disais qu'on
poursuivait avec le réseau flamme
représenté par Madame Maryse Combre et
Monsieur Rémy chabrillat également en
visio
très bien bien écoutez je vais vous
faire dans un premier temps alors tout
d'abord merci pour votre invitation une
présentation du réseau et des agences
locales d'énergie du climat et puis je
passerai la parole à
Rémi chabriac qui est donc président
d'une Alec de la lettre du Puy-de-Dôme
précisément donc le réseau flamme donc
le réseau fédère une quarantaine
d'agences locales de l'énergie et du
climat qui permet ce réseau d'échanger
les expériences de façon permanente
entre chacune de ces agences sur de
nombreux territoires et entre autres
justement entre les différents
conseillers en énergie partagée ou
assimilée
forte de 25 ans d'expérience mutualisées
l'action des agences couvre 23 millions
d'habitants il y a plus de 600 salariés
qui sont au service de 14 métropoles 50
communautés d'agglo et 200 communautés
de communes
et la quasi-totalité des Alecs sont
porteuses entre autres du guichet France
rénov qui est donc un guichet dédié aux
particuliers au copro et aux entreprises
les agences locales de l'énergie du
climat sont reconnus dans le code de
l'énergie à l'article
l211-5-1 pour accompagner les
collectivités locales dans leur
politique énergique climat dans une
démarche neutre et indépendante elles
mettent leur expertise au service de
l'intérêt général elle possède une
vision territoriale des plus larges qui
leur permet justement de conjuguer de
façon
permanente tous les enjeux de sobriété
d'efficaces énergétique et de
développement d'énergie renouvelable et
tout cela bien évidemment au bénéfice
des collectivités locales donc ce sont
des agences d'ingéniorité territoriales
qui sont mutualisées parce que comme l'a
dit tout à l'heure monsieur de la dame
justement pour pouvoir optimiser au
maximum ces CEP il faut les mutualiser
au sein des collectivités
nos agences sont portées essentiellement
pratiquement
quasi pratiquement toutes à plusieurs
niveaux institutionnels dans plusieurs
niveaux de collectivité
ce sont des outils qui sont vraiment au
service de des élus locaux puisqu'elles
sont vraiment en proximité elles
favorise donc l'émergence de projets et
elles permettent aussi de par leur
constitution de mettre autour de la
table tous les acteurs concernés de la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments qui
est bien évidemment un élément clé de la
transition énergétique que nous appelons
de nos vœux de façon très concrète les
allées qu'on accompagné à peu près plus
de 1000 rénovations de bâtiments
scolaires ce qui leur permet d'avoir un
retour d'expérience très concret précis
en la matière alors j'avais imaginé vous
donner des des constats liés vraiment à
quelques difficultés je sais pas si ça
vous intéresse
tout de suite justement accompagnements
des collectivités est-ce que vous voulez
que je voulais soumettre très brièvement
donc bon évidemment les écoles sont des
bâtiments qui sont qui ont une haute
valeur symbolique auprès des dans le
patrimoine public des collectivités ce
sont les bâtiments qui sont souvent les
plus représentés et plus ils sont grands
plus ils sont consommateurs bien
évidemment et ces grands bâtiments sont
en général soumis donc au décrétaires
les bâtiments sont souvent ces bâtiments
que l'on a rencontré sont souvent sous
forte dépendance aux énergies fossiles
ce sont des bâtiments avec de grandes
surfaces vitrées pour la plupart du
temps
et qui font que les classes deviennent
des études et en même temps ce sont
j'allais dire les éléments qui coûtent
un petit peu cher
sur le champ de la rénovation
en général ce qu'on a constaté aussi
c'est que les ventilations étaient très
insuffisantes donc il y avait des
problématiques de qualité de l'air
[Musique]
l'intégration de la rénovation aussi on
rencontre en ce moment l'intégration de
la rénovation des cours d'école avec les
envies de végétalisation des cours
d'école qui se lit au projet de
rénovation du bâtiment et évidemment
pour les collectivités ça nécessite non
seulement des compétences spécifiques
pour cette partie là mais aussi ça
augmente le coût du projet
ce qu'on a constaté aussi c'est que une
fois que des rénovations ont été
achevées il y avait peu de régulation de
chauffage qui minimisent les économies
d'énergie et ces rénovations se termine
souvent sans programmation du chauffage
ou de la ventilation et c'est souvent
d'ailleurs un travail qui est confié au
CEP qui achève cette
de façon à rendre vraiment plus
performant
l'efficacité énergétique la rénovation
de ces bâtiments donc beaucoup de ces
rénovations n'atteignent pas les
performances pour cause de
dysfonctionnement d'équipements ou de
mauvais réglages comme je l'ai dit
précédemment
le fait de bien régler bien réguler tout
l'équipement est très important parce
que parfois il faut attendre deux ans
avant d'avoir atteint des performances
attendues lorsque l'on a posé le projet
au départ
nous avons des difficultés aussi d'avoir
des projets de rénovation globale avec
un gain énergétique important de l'ordre
de 40 à 60% et les petites actions qui
sont parfois menées stop justement cette
potentialité de rénovation globale
ce qui a impulsé souvent de rentrer dans
une rénovation sur ces bâtissements
scolaires
ce qui va enclenché en fait le souhait
des élus c'est très souvent lié à une
fin de vie d'équipement ou à une
dégradation du bâti mais pas forcément
encore enfin à aujourd'hui en tout cas
par une volonté manifeste de réduire la
consommation d'énergie même si
actuellement c'est vraiment un petit peu
au cœur du sujet
donc le rôle que nous avons c'est
fréquemment de faire comprendre aux élus
que une rénovation globale c'est elle
qui va déterminer le dimensionnement des
équipements et donc d'envisager la
potentialité éventuellement aussi de
poser des énergies renouvelables des des
photos Volta sur les différents toits de
ces bâtiments puisqu'il y en a quand
même pas mal les classes les préaux la
cantine enfin voilà tout ce qui peut
être exploité sur le champ des énergies
renouvelables c'est un potentiel que
l'on peut justement
suggérer et fait partie aussi du rôle
global du CEP
donc le
problème de surchauffe aussi dans les
classes a été un enclencheur de projet
de rénovation
mais malheureusement encore une fois de
temps en temps les communes se
contentent d'installer des packs sans
faire sans rentrer vraiment dans un
projet de rénovation globale alors ce
qui peut empêcher peut-être de passer à
l'acte ou de rendre cet acte moins
performant il y a des éléments qui sont
parfois un peu des spécificités
politiques mais aussi organisationnel la
rénovation de l'école d'une école dans
les petites communes j'entends et le
projet du mandat donc c'est un petit peu
compliqué de s'engager dans ce projet
qui va pour certaines petites communes
donc contraindre énormément au niveau du
budget
après il y a aussi des questions un peu
plus organisationnelles qui sont sur le
maintien ou pas de certaines classes
dans les territoires ruraux donc qui
freinent enfin en tout cas qui
n'encourage pas à rénover et puis les
problèmes liés aux périodes de travaux
les périodes de vacances étant
contrainte tout un si on rentre dans un
champ de rénovation globale deux mois ne
suffisent pas bien évidemment à pouvoir
faire l'entièreté des travaux donc c'est
très hachuré et voilà et des fois ça
coûte des fois peut-être un petit peu
plus cher et voilà donc il y a aussi ce
que l'on a rencontré la nécessité de la
sensibilisation du corps enseignant
parce que bien évidemment qu'il y a en
amont cette sensibilité et ça fait
partie aussi de ces rôles de des rôles
du CEP de sensibiliser aussi bien les
élus que les agents justement sur les
économies d'énergie
qui sont d'ailleurs pour les enseignants
exploités sur sur des supports
pédagogiques et c'est et c'est très bien
mais il est vraiment nécessaire de
sensibiliser la majorité de ces usagers
utilisateurs et certaines de nos agences
d'ailleurs ont obtenu une baisse de 30 à
50% de consommation dans certaines
écoles grâce à des actions
anti-gaspillage sur le chauffage et la
ventilation donc visser pardon
non
viser l'amélioration des comportements
donc c'est nécessaire évidemment c'est
nécessaire mais aussi nécessaire
j'allais dire que la rénovation
elle-même donc c'est pour ça que les
Alecs ont élaboré divers guides dédiés
des guides d'accompagnement pour la
rénovation à destination des élus mais
aussi des guides dédiés aux
usagers utilisateurs voilà et en termes
de NR donc il y a souvent du potentiel
PV comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure mais
mais il y a la problématique de la
non-consommation d'été mais ça peut être
aussi peut-être l'opportunité de penser
à une autoconsommation collective et
c'est soit en quoi cette vision globale
qu'apporte les CEP en matière de
politique publique
étendu élargi sur le l'énergie climat
peut avoir justement cette vision qui
n'est pas étroite des choses
donc voilà après il y a
quelques-uns pour Monsieur Chabrier le
pauvre il a plutôt de parole
si vous avez
pas le temps
c'est juste que je n'arrivais pas à
remettre mon micro je m'en excuse
vivement bon merci non mais il y a déjà
pas mal de choses qui ont été dites sur
le CEP pas mal de choses qui ont été
dites sur les bâtiments scolaires sur
quoi je voulais peut-être à ce moment
focaliser si vous voulez bien c'est un
peu c'est un peu sur le CEP et le sa
mise en oeuvre dans mon département et
puis sur une expérience qui est en cours
en terme de rénovation bâtiments
scolaire et un certain nombre de
questions qu'on peut se poser derrière
et en termes de complémentarité des
acteurs et en termes de financement
concernant donc le CEP donc c'était
excellent présenté par mon mon ancien
collègue Christophe le stage puisque je
dois dire je suis récemment retraité de
l'ADEME et présidente de Clermont charge
de l'énergie et président de cette Alex
qui s'appelle l'adulte qui est plus
ancienne qui a été fait en 1996 et qui
elle fait du conseil en énergie partagée
depuis 2002
donc non pas les pas parmi les premiers
bretons mais peu de temps après et
aujourd'hui le conseiller en énergie
partagée dans le Puy-de-Dôme c'est 12
conseillers pour aujourd'hui toutes les
communes du département sauf 5 sur les
464 communes alors avec des montages
essentiellement via les EPCI mais
aujourd'hui l'essentiel des communes du
département bénéficient d'un service de
conseil en énergie partagée j'insiste
sur ce chiffre
pour nous on considère que on est
aujourd'hui on s'interroge sur comment
arriver encore à monter en puissance
parce que sur 464 communes 12
conseillers ça nous paraît vraiment être
un niveau nécessaire pour assurer voilà
l'ensemble du service qui était évoqué
tout à l'heure par Christophe lestage
le diagnostic du patrimoine le bilan de
suivi des consos l'établissement de
programme d'action
à court terme à long terme
l'accompagnement dans les projets tout
ça ça mobilise du temps et ça donne des
résultats à condition qu'on mobilise ce
et si on doit réfléchir à la
généralisation de vraiment on disait
tout à l'heure qu'il y a des CEP pour
8000 communes mais que dans certains
départements il y en a que deux il y a
que deux conseillers voilà une douzaine
de conseillers pour un département comme
le Puy-de-Dôme ça nous paraît être un
minimum
ensuite que on articule comme beaucoup
d'autres comme beaucoup d'autres agences
locales de l'énergie on articule ces
missions de conseil en énergie partagée
avec le montage de propositions
d'actions collectives en aval sur des
sujets qu'on a identifié à travers le
CEV sur lequel dia potentiellement des
reproductivités évidemment des problèmes
que qui se posent que plein de communes
rencontres la possibilité d'obtenir des
économies d'échelle des économies
financières et pour donner des exemples
on a amené dans les années passées un
programme s'appelait coco 63 63 qui
était un programme de rénovation des
combles où on a diagnostiqué des
milliers de bâtiments communaux et avec
le Conseil départemental qui a joué un
rôle de maîtrise on a isolé plus de
100000 m² de combles avec l'économie
derrière on a monté un programme qui
s'appelle solaire dôme avec des analyses
opportunités sur toutes les toitures des
bâtiments publics des communes et EPCI
pour en finale
identifier la possibilité de réalisation
de réaliser d'installation
photovoltaïques 400 installations
aujourd'hui envisagé on a enfin on monte
encore avec le Conseil départemental et
j'y reviendrai dans une seconde sur les
collaborations un programme de en gros
on va chercher avec le département à
éradiquer les chadière fioules les
propanes sur le patrimoine des
collectivités pour les remplacer par des
énergies renouvelables thermiques
notamment notamment pour les géothermie
et enfin on anime toujours avec le
Conseil départemental un groupement
d'achat électricité plus gaz qui
concerne une centaine de communes les
plus grosses en groupe puisqu'il y a un
deuxième groupe qui est alimenté par le
Syndicat des partants une centaine de
communes plus des bailleurs le CHU etc
ce deuxième point sur lequel je voulais
dire un mot c'est cette notion de
complémentarité et de travailler en
commun à la différence de beaucoup
d'autres
agences locales de l'énergie du climat
l'abîme n'a pas de mission de conseils
particuliers tout simplement parce que
historiquement celle-ci était assurée
par l'adilation de l'information donc on
s'est inscrit en complémentarité on est
aussi en complémentarité avec le
Syndicat indépendantal des énergies avec
lequel on a signé des conventions
récemment pour travailler notamment sur
la chaleur renouvelable en gros nos
conseillers en énergie partagée
identifient des besoins de collectivité
sur des installations de chaleur
renouvelables et le syndicat
départemental à travers une convention
avec l'ADEME mobilise des financements
qui vont permettre de financer ces
projets et par ailleurs est en train de
recruter du personnel pour être capable
d'assurer derrière une mission de
maîtrise ouvrage délégué pour pour les
communes qui n'auraient pas les moyens
de monter elle-même ce type de projet
donc cette notion vous évoquez tout à
l'heure monsieur le Président le le
marais de le marais du positionnement de
l'un des autres bon dans le département
on essaie de faire en sorte que ça soit
plutôt un jardin à peu près ordonné avec
différentes partitions une partie
peut-être non je vais je vais arrêter de
filer cette métaphore du jardin je suis
sûr qu'elle marche très bien mais voilà
on
les acteurs du département cherchent à
faire en sorte qu'on se retrouve tous
sur un voilà pour apporter un service le
plus coordonné et le plus efficace
possible près des collectivités il y a
trop de boulot pour que en plus il y a
trop de choses à faire pour qu'en plus
on perd du temps et de l'énergie à à se
battre pour pour des sujets il vaut
beaucoup mieux essayer de le faire
ensemble concernant le
il a un micro qui a été branché qui fait
un écho là il vient de fermer concernant
le programme acté et
les spécifiquement les questions de
rénovation des écoles donc un certain
nombre d'Aleg qui ont répondu à acte
général en partenariat avec d'autres
structures notamment les syndicats
d'énergie pour ce qui nous concerne dans
le Puy-de-Dôme donc comme j'ai évoqué on
a répondu avec le département et la
démarche qui a été lancée c'est un appel
à projet auprès des communes pour en
gros qui est candidat et on va
accompagner 20 écoles ce n'est qu'un
début
l'idée c'est qu'on a donc on a choisi 20
écoles dans un certain nombre de
communes on a mis en place entre
guillemets un club de ces porteurs de
projets dans lequel il y a des élus des
techniciens le Conseil départemental et
la dune qui se réunit régulièrement
la dû m'a accompagné et le département
accompagné les écoles les communes pour
le choix de bureau d'études les
réalisations des études sont en cours
donc les études de les diagnostics
détaillés et ensuite les propositions de
plan de rénovation on en est à cette
phase là avec des mises en commun
régulière et ensuite on accompagnera
pour le montage des projets et le
montage des plantes financement et la
réalisation en parallèle avec
un travail sur 20 nouvelles rénovations
on a mis en place un suivi des
performances de 5 écoles déjà
réhabilités pour optimiser le retour
d'expérience et pouvoir au mieux
orienter les choix en regardant ce qui
marche les choix de ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui enfin une petite chose un
petit point et j'en auraient être fini
en attente de vos telles questions sur
la question des financements bon il y a
pour tous les projets de rénovation ça
vaut pour les rénovations des écoles ça
ou pour tout le reste il y a
effectivement alors vous parliez vous
parliez de Maki tout à l'heure
dans certaines zones ou dans certaines
situations pour les les intervenants il
y a clairement une multiplicité des
aides financières qui rend leur accès
compliqué la dstr le fond vert les fonds
de concours locaux d'hiver et variés
laisser deux heures des appels à projets
certains pérennes d'autres la plupart
n'ont pérenne la plupart une grande
majorité variable plus ou moins variable
dans le temps et c'est très compliqué de
prédire ou d'indiquer le montant d'aide
dont on pourra bénéficier la commune
pour son projet de rénovation école ou
le reste d'ailleurs
et donc c'est compliqué pour la commune
de s'engager sans compter le fait que il
sera pareil ensuite éventuellement
compliqué de mobiliser les certificats
d'économie d'énergie et que sans même
parler de la difficulté de se
positionner dans ce dans ce maquis les
délais de prise de décision pour les
êtres on va pas complexe donc on
rêverait dans l'idéal de quelque chose
qui pourrait être
une aide simple forfaitaire comme les
ailes de l'ADEME comme comme la dame en
a mis en place pour le financement des
petites moyennes installations dans le
cadre du fond chaleur pour les projets
de rénovation par exemple tant d'euros
le mètre carré pour atteindre les - 40 %
que demande le décrire en 2030 avec un
bonus si on anticipe sur le -50 - 60%
prévu par en 2040 et 2050 un minima il y
a vraiment un sujet de
vraiment d'améliorer la visibilité
peut-être de mettre en place des clubs
de financeurs ça a existé j'en ai
personnellement vécu en Auvergne pendant
plusieurs années entre la région les 4
départements l'ADEME et le FEDER où il y
avait un mécanisme conjoint de
financement des projets d'énergies
renouvelables qui du coup donner une
visibilité aux communes il y a des
choses comme ça qui sont à réinventer
enfin Monsieur monsieur
chabrison c'est l'ingénierie
territoriale locale elle est
indispensable et elle mériterait d'être
mieux financé pour en permettre la
pérennité on a bien vu tout à l'heure on
évoquait bon l'ADEME
comment fait-on ensuite
parfois pas simple et c'est y compris
pour ça que la couverture du territoire
est insatisfaisante donc il y a un sujet
de pérennisation du financement de
l'ingénierie financière merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup je suggère que Monsieur
sentier intervienne tout à l'heure
puisque pour le réseau flamme il y a
déjà eu deux prises de parole
conséquentes en tout cas très
intéressante je propose maintenant
monsieur Berto pour le compte de de du
cerema d'intervenir
en tant qu'expertise nationale
intervient sur ce domaine d'une part
d'abord dans les programmes cubes cubes
pour les lycées et les collèges avec nos
amis de l'espèbes cubécoles pour les
écoles publiques avec nos amis de
l'ifèbes et nos amis d'acte et
effectivement lorsqu'ils auront
l'occasion de parler du programme c'est
un programme qui fonctionne assez bien
dans les écoles qui permettent de faire
le premier geste par rapport à ce qui
est ce qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure
par flamme et effectivement d'avoir
finalement à bas prix 10 15 20%
d'économies d'énergie avec un double
effet il y a à la fois l'effet immédiat
mais aussi derrière l'effet de
mobilisation et justement de capacité
des gens à aller trouver l'argent pour
faire des travaux plus structurels
intervenants aussi dans le cadre du
Programme national d'accompagnement de
la mise en oeuvre du dispositif éco
énergie tertiaire en particulier en
matière de formation et d'animation
nationale des référents
nous intervenons aussi sur un hub air
énergie en partenariat avec liftp pour
améliorer la qualité de l'air intérieur
tout en préservant les consommations
d'énergie et pour trouver des solutions
conciliant confort des usagers et
économies d'énergie aujourd'hui une
expérimentation sur 10 établissements
scolaires qui fonctionnent pas mal et là
aussi évidemment l'idée c'est de
l'amplifier assez largement
au-delà de ça nous c'est vraiment
propose aux collectivités une offre de
services agir pour l'école de demain en
agissant à la fois sur le bâtiment avec
une stratégie patrimoniale diagnostic de
parc priorisation des sites etc mise en
place de démarche de sobriété
optimisation de l'exploitation des
bâtiments une action à côté sur
l'aménagement des cours d'école qui est
pour nous un sujet essentiel et
notamment en matière de végétalisation
et une action sur les espaces publics et
l'accessibilité des abords cette offre
de services en fait elle repose
évidemment sur l'expertise transversale
qu'on a la chance d'avoir au sérréma et
une expérience confirmée bien sûr auprès
des établissements scolaires avec une
diffusion qui évidemment assez large
puisque céréma est aujourd'hui présent
dans 23 villes en France donc on a un
réseau qui couvre assez bien l'essentiel
de la métropole et de l'outre-mer
d'ailleurs depuis deux ans et avec
effectivement une logique assez
fédératrice
du coup effectivement on intervient
directement auprès des collectivités
encore plus d'ici quelques semaines
puisque grâce à l'excellente loi 3DS
votez l'an dernier nous avons changé les
statuts du CRMA et nous devrions des le
16 mai pouvoir avoir une nouvelle
gouvernance et donc des relations avec
les collectivités adhérentes en quasi
régie qui permettront évidemment
d'avancer beaucoup plus vite j'en
profite d'ailleurs sur ce sujet pour
vous dire que c'est un grand succès
parce que ce jour nous avons
634 adhérents dont 80% des régions 70%
des départements et à peu près
25300 interco 250 300 collectivités
alors j'en viens d'ailleurs justement
aux questions que vous avez pu poser
d'abord sur le maki des offres c'est un
sujet qu'on entend souvent moi je crois
qu'il faut voir qu'on est sur des sujets
qui sont particulièrement ex et qu'en
réalité derrière cette question de Maki
des offres il y a surtout une question
de des compétences nécessaires et en
tout cas je peux vous dire qu'entre
établissement public on l'a fait avec le
BRGM on l'a fait avec le CSTB on l'a
fait avec d'autres quand on met à plat
un sujet on s'aperçoit que les
redondances réelles sont en réalité
assez faibles
par contre évidemment la difficulté et
où là on vous rejoint tout à fait c'est
pour une collectivité ça fait un tas
d'interlocuteurs c'est pas toujours très
simple de comprendre et c'est vrai qu'il
nous semble important probablement qu'au
niveau départemental ça pourrait être le
rôle de délégation départementale de la
NCT d'avoir justement une espèce de
point d'entrée unique qui permet
justement de justement de techniciens
d'ingénieurs qui sachent ah bah pour tel
sujet il faut aller chercher machin dans
tel organisme etc donc je pense que
c'est pas à travers l'idée de dire on
veut voir qu'une seule tête qu'on en
sortira par contre il y a probablement
effectivement besoin d'un interprète si
j'ose dire une espèce de point d'entrée
unique entre nous il y a des gens dans
les DDT donc c'est pas si compliqué à
mettre en place et je suis persuadé que
ça améliorerait très largement le
fonctionnement du dispositif sur
les différents organismes de l'exemple
pour le programme cube effectivement
on est capable de monter effectivement
des projets en commun ici et du reste
évidemment c'est c'est ce qu'il nous
semble effectivement pouvoir enfin de
voir être privilégié et c'est vrai qu'au
céréma on s'attache beaucoup à ça quelle
que soit le sujet à aller chercher
effectivement tel organise de
collectivité telle association pour
essayer de bâtir justement des produits
qui soient
effectivement globalisant et qui
permettent à la collectivité d'avoir
quelque chose clé en main qui qui
fonctionne assez bien
deuxième point peut-être sur la question
des documentations et c'est vrai que
c'est un sujet important alors c'est un
sujet qu'on connaît bien au cerema
puisque vraiment on a une mission assez
forte de diffusion de l'information à
travers la mise en place de centre de
ressources la mise en place de centre de
documentation assez fort et c'est vrai
que je pense que typiquement sur ce
sujet scolaire ça vaudrait le coup
d'aller un peu plus loin que ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui et pourquoi pas de
mettre en place un centre de ressources
sur justement l'énergie dans les dans
les bâtiments scolaires pourraient
j'imagine le faire avec en gros les gens
qui sont autour de la table aujourd'hui
on l'a fait pour l'adaptation au
changement climatique donc je veux dire
c'est pas très très compliqué à faire et
encore une fois je peux vous assurer que
je pense me faire le porte-parole des
organismes qui sont autour de la table
pour dire que travailler ensemble on
demande que ça quoi
dernier point sur l'accès l'accès à
l'expertise pour les communes moi je
voudrais dire deux choses par rapport à
ça la première c'est que
il y a une question de taille des
communes et c'est vrai qu'au céréma nous
on a plutôt tendance à pousser vers
l'intercommunalité avec un argument qui
est un exemple
nous avons grâce d'ailleurs au Sénat
lancé le programme pompe pour expertiser
les ponts des collectivités exactes on a
réussi à en toucher 12000 on pense donc
à 28 000 collectivités
on pensait qu'il y en avait 18 20 000
qui avaient des ponts
voilà la cible si vous laissez 28 000
sur les 28000 il y en avait 18 20 000
qui avaient des ponts on a réussi à en
toucher 12000 c'est pas mal mais enfin
on a mis 6 mois on a travaillé avec les
associations de mer on a travaillé avec
les services de l'État les préfets etc
on a quand même mis 6 mois pour obtenir
de ces 12000 communes en l'occurrence
simplement un mail qui disent oui je
suis d'accord pour que vous veniez
ausculter mes peaux puisque pour les
communes c'était gratuit c'était financé
justement sur le budget de l'État donc
faut avoir conscience que si on veut
monter des programmes avec une certaine
ampleur aujourd'hui à l'échelle
communale pour les toutes petites
communes bien évidemment franchement
c'est très compliqué je peux vous dire
là vraiment c'est un exemple on a on a
essayé et donc c'est vrai que nous on
pousse plutôt vers en tout cas un
regroupement de communes même si c'est
pas l'interco parce que bien conscient
des problèmes entre la ville centre les
communes etc mais simplement la question
de la massification passe quand même à
un moment par des regroupements de
communes et puis deuxième point c'est
qu'effectivement nous pour pouvoir
faciliter l'appui au commune on a mis en
place un dispositif simple qui est
effectivement le changement de statut du
céréma avec cette idée qui est
effectivement simplissime c'est que dès
lors qu'une commune adhère au cerema de
fait on peut effectivement la conseiller
dans des conditions à la fois
financières et surtout administratives
qui sont radicalement simplifiées
puisque vis-à-vis de la commune on se
retrouve comme finalement comme son
agence d'urbaniste à SPL etc voilà donc
en réalité tout ça pour dire que nous
nous pensons qu'il y a effectivement des
solutions qu'on est tout à fait capable
de les mettre en place je pense que tous
les organismes autour de la table sont
assez d'accord pour pour avancer et pour
simplifier les choses mais encore une
fois je crois qu'il faut pas jeter le
bébé avec l'eau d'humain il y a on a des
sujets qui sont de toute façon assez
complexes et on ne réduira pas cette
complexité par contre on peut très
largement la simplifier pour les
collectivités
très bien
[Musique]
partager dans l'approche globale de
cette rénovation des écoles et l'autre
approche c'est l'approche holistique
l'approche globale rebondir sur une
image qui a utilisé Rémi Chabrier tout à
l'heure de potager en l'occurrence vous
savez qu'on a réussi jamais aussi bien
un potager qu'on avait arrive à
diversifier ce qu'il y a dans le potager
et puis avoir des influences centre les
différentes plantes en l'occurrence ça
permet aussi d'avoir effectivement une
approche à l'échelle du patrimoine ça
c'est le premier élément à savoir
qu'effectivement à l'école est un
élément patrimonial de la collectivité
et qu'une approche certes à l'échelle du
bâtis scolaire est importante mais doit
s'inscrire dans une approche politique
plus large et c'est un peu en ce sens
que nous ont donné mandat nos différents
élus la SNCF d'une part la MF également
qui est partenaire sur ce programme là
l'autre élément l'approche holistique
sur effectivement la nécessité de
considérer la rénovation énergétique
comme une étape vers une rénovation
globale dans son approche la plus large
énergétique mais aussi avec tous les
éléments les externalités qui en
résultent il faut considérer
effectivement l'équilibre économique de
la rénovation éner par rapport aux
économies d'énergie donc les économies
sur la facture qui en résultent mais
également aussi par un certain d'autres
économies non quantifiables mais
directement perceptibles comme le sont
la qualité de l'air l'acoustique
particulièrement intéressante dans les
écoles à ces niveaux là la luminosité
etc quand vous changez un double vitrage
vous agissez certes sur la facture
énergétique moi aussi sur chacun des
trois items que j'ai pu mentionner avec
un impact direct sur la concentration au
niveau du public scolaire et la confort
d'usage de manière assez globale dans
les écoles on touche du coup une
approche vraiment de projet politique au
niveau des élus locaux qui est
particulièrement prenant dans ce avec ce
contexte de ces deux éléments
partenariaux d'une part
holistique global d'autre part on
s'appuie sur trois grands éléments au
niveau d'acté donc notre programme on la
montée il y a quatre ans maintenant avec
une montée en charge conséquente passer
12 millions d'euros à 110 millions
d'euros à 220 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui dans la mouture qui
s'ouvrira le mois prochain construit de
manière partenariale un certain nombre
d'acteur aux alentours de table en
témoigné et je les ai en remercie que ce
soit en table physique ou entables
virtuel je salue sur la distance
également pour effectivement mettre en
place une dynamique de réseau partagé
donc on a développé des postes
complémentaires au concert d'énergie
partagée tels ont été présentés par
l'ADEME notamment les économes de flux
actés qui viennent compléter le mariage
le mariage territorial des conseillers
en énergie partagée qui viennent aussi
compléter le cas échéant lorsqu'ils sont
plusieurs sur un territoire les
compétences en s'attachant en
particulier à l'approche de bouclage de
plan de financement c'est ça qui est
particulièrement intéressant la
connaissance du bâti et la manière de
prioriser les actions sont importantes
la connaissance également des outils de
financement qui permettent ce passage à
l'action on est essentiel d'où
l'importance effectivement d'avoir ce
conseil local en flux financier
également connaître le mécanisme des
certificats économie d'énergie les
différentes aides qui peuvent exister
sur le terrain les différents outils
juridiques et financiers je vais citer
notamment le sépul contre la performance
énergétique qui effectivement
d'alimenter la réflexion au niveau des
élus le deuxième élément c'est autour
d'une approche de centre de ressources
alors Pascal tu l'as très bien mentionné
on a un certain nombre à travailler sur
des outils permettant effectivement de
le passage à l'acte d'accompagner la
connaissance du patrimoine j'en citerai
deux qu'on a produit le schéma directeur
immobilier énergie avec un cahier des
charges type en subventionne aussi pour
que les collectivités à cette vision
globale sur leur patrimoine savoir
prioriser savoir rassembler certains
types de bâtiments pour aider ce passage
à l'action d'une part effectivement ce
kit contrat de performance énergétique
sans en faire la solution absolue ça
serait pas uniquement avec ce biais là
qu'on résoudra la totalité la
problématique mais en travaillant sur
des rassemblements des regroupements
mutualisation d'un certain nombre de
bâtis on arrive à avoir des contrats
extrêmement équilibrés et l'approche qui
était celle de la loi tient financement
récent des différentes discussions qui
en sont évidemment
issus et préludés à son adoption vont au
son de nature effectivement à renforcer
cette approche de passage à l'acte avec
des outils juridiques ou financiers
effectif évidemment assez assénébreux là
le troisième élément sur lequel je
voulais insister est effectivement
l'approche financière alors je rejoins
globalement ce qui était dit sur
effectivement je ne vous dirais pas qui
nous manque de l'argent pour rénover
dans au niveau des collectivités
globalement on a un certain nombre de
dispositifs de financement qui sont
présents un maquis non pas dans le sens
de regroupement parce que tu insisté
là-dessus et je te rejoins parfaitement
mais makis dans le sens des dispositifs
assez diversifiés et pour se repérer
dans le maquis il faut connaître le
maquille en l'occurrence on essaie un
petit peu cette approche là avec nos
collègues des DDT mais aussi directement
avec les économes de fluxacter tout cet
aspect financier qui nous semble
important à mettre en avant en plus de
l'aspect technique de conseils qui doit
être porté assez niveau là j'ajouterai
encore un dernier point pour conclure
peut-être les points que je souhaitais
partager avec vous et je vous remercie
de nous avoir permis de les énoncer
aujourd'hui autour effectivement d'une
réflexion qu'on a avec la banque des
territoires pour chercher à bonifier nos
aides dans le cadre nos aides
financières ont finances effectivement
les économes de flux les audits les
schémas directeurs immobiliers énergies
notamment dans une approche patrimoniale
chercher à bonifier effectivement le
bâti scolaire mais toujours dans cette
approche globale de stratégie
immobilière et d'approche holistique
incluant certes les économies d'énergie
et également cette question de confort
de confort de vie et de maîtrise des
usages avec évidemment l'appui très
efficace on dira peut-être plus en
détail tout à l'heure de la dynamique
partenariat qu'on a avec nos collègues
de l'ifpe du RMA sur cube école et des
cubes un petit peu plus élargés aussi
sur l'ensemble du patrimoine voilà ce
que je pouvais vous partagez aujourd'hui
vous voyez que dans le tour de table des
acteurs on a un unissant sur ce côté
partenariat j'ajoute vraiment la
dimension holistique et évidemment le
côté book lâcher lancé conseil local
avec des ressources qui sont
essentielles merci à vous ça fait
plaisir est-ce que Monsieur Carteron
souhaite compléter
il a tout mis tout dit tout bien dit
très bien je propose maintenant
de donner la parole au CMU
monsieur Renaud Barrès
[Musique]
chambre à ce qui va commencer je
prendrai sa suite parce que la
présentation globale et je suis tiré
dans le détail très bien je vous en prie
merci merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs de
nous donner l'opportunité de présenter
aujourd'hui le rôle et les actions des
ce en matière de bâtie scolaire
donc en un mot sur les structures que
sont les ciao elles ont été créées par
la loi sur l'architecture de 77 qui leur
confère plusieurs missions pour
concourir à la promotion de la qualité
du cadre de vie il s'agit de
l'information de la sensibilisation de
la formation et du conseil sur les
questions d'architecture d'urbanisme de
l'environnement et du paysage le tout en
exerçant leur mission gratuitement
puisqu'elles sont financées par une
partie de la taxe d'aménagement
les publics visés sont larges cela va
des élus et collectivités aux
particuliers en passant par les
professionnels et les publics scolaires
et concernant plus spécifiquement le
bâti scolaire le réseau des 92 c'est eu
est impliqué de longues dates sur ce
sujet et ce à l'échelle départementale
c'est en effet une problématique
transversale qui on l'a vu concerne à la
fois les territoires urbains comme
l'Euro avec cependant d'importantes
différences en termes de dynamique
démographique et donc de besoin en
papier scolaire et en termes de
ressources financières et humaines
et plus précisément les actions de DCU
portent à la fois sur l'existant
c'est-à-dire l'accompagnement à la
rénovation et à la réhabilitation
notamment sur les cours d'école la
question de l'intégration des usages ou
encore la préservation de la qualité
architecturale lorsqu'il y a des
rénovations
mais les actions portent aussi sur les
projets futurs en visant à promouvoir
des pratiques vertueuses qu'il s'agisse
d'architecture bioclimatique de sobriété
énergétiques ou de mutualisation des
établissements afin de minimiser le
nombre par leur nombre
et
on peut dire que les actions des c.u en
matière de bâtie scolaire recouvre leur
mission prévue par la loi de 77 puisque
donc un premier axe serait l'information
et la production et la fourniture de
ressources pour mettre à disposition des
connaissances des exemples inspiration
donc renaud-barrès pourra revenir par
exemple sur des études menées sur le
genre et comment on l'intègre dans
l'aménagement des cours d'école il y a
d'autres exemples par exemple ça a eu du
Calvados qui propose un cahier sur
l'école de demain pour prendre en compte
la qualité de vie l'adaptabilité du bâti
sur le deuxième volet qui est celui de
la sensibilisation il s'agit de toucher
les différents publics que sont les
décisionnaires donc les élus et les
collectivités les professionnels qui
vont mettre en oeuvre les
transformations et presque surtout les
usagers du bâti scolaire donc il
s'agisse des élèves comme des personnels
enseignants ou à des permettre une prise
de conscience des enjeux donc notamment
pour les élèves puisque la cour est
l'école sont finalement les premiers
espaces publics qui vont fréquenter
or ce sont des citoyens en devenir
particulièrement important de
d'introduire cette dimension et ça va
aussi favoriser une acceptation en cas
de nouveaux aménagements divers moyens
qu'on utilisait par les cieux il peut
s'agir d'ateliers avec les élèves
d'exposition ou encore des visites
ateliers ou les élus et professionnels
sont invités à visiter des sites qui
sont vertueux afin de s'inspirer et
d'échanger avec les maîtres d'oeuvre et
mettre d'ouvrage qui ont conçu ces sites
le troisième volet est celui de la
formation pour permettre une montée en
compétences des acteurs et une diffusion
des savoirs par exemple le ciao de Paris
propose une formation aux agents de la
ville et aux enseignants sur les cours
d'école oasis et enfin le dernier volet
c'est celui du conseil et de
l'accompagnement qui a lieu ici en amont
du projet et ils vise à aider dans la
définition des besoins et des projets
notamment pour prendre en compte et
intégrer les divers usages la modularité
l'intégration d'usage hors temps
scolaire et l'ouverture des écoles
ils vise également à rassembler les
différentes parties prenantes le plus en
amont possible et faire participer les
acteurs pour notamment instaurer des
démarches de co-construction par exemple
avec des ateliers avec les élus les
équipes pédagogiques les élèves
et cette démarche présente de nombreuses
intérêts à la fois l'implication le plus
en amont et la création d'une culture
commune autour du projet ce qui est un
facteur clé de succès
et
faire de chaque acteur
un véritable déterminant du projet et
c'est particulièrement important pour
les élèves qui sont
sensibilisés à la gestion de projet et
la participation citoyenne après cette
présentation
du CU des Pyrénées-Atlantiques merci
merci
vous avez la parole oui merci beaucoup
et bien alors la question des écoles oui
en effet c'est le bâti aussi beaucoup
des acteurs n'ont déjà parlé sont des
acteurs qu'on connaît et qu'on croise
très régulièrement alors le bâti pour
faire très court parce que je vais
plutôt me concentrer sur le sur les
cours le bâti l'intérêt de pour les
communes de faire appel au Cius c'est
vrai que c'est d'avoir évidemment un
regard de professionnel qui qui touche
notamment à l'architecture et au
patrimoine et si je prends un exemple
très précis lorsque directeur du seuil
de l'Aude les cieux d'Occitanie avait
fait une une étude financée par le
fanfédère sur qui montrait que la
rénovation du bâti ancien était
évidemment pas la même en fonction des
territoires en fonction des climats etc
et un exemple montré par exemple qu'une
construction en isolée en construction
en brique à Toulouse vous l'isolez par
l'intérieur et en croyant bien faire et
du jour au lendemain vous doublez le
nombre de jours d'inconfort d'été donc
ça nous montre simplement que cocher des
cases en disant j'ai isolé ça peut être
une bonne idée ça n'est pas forcément
une et le confort d'été devient
extrêmement prépondérant parce que il
concernait pas les écoles il y a encore
quelques années puisqu'elle était fermée
l'été mais c'est plus le cas donc pour
se concentrer un peu sur les cours
d'école c'est un sujet qui est
énormément monté sur lequel on a
beaucoup de demandes alors c'est
beaucoup monté depuis évidemment de
confinement parce que les gens se sont
rendus compte que finalement la nature
leur manquait beaucoup et c'est vrai que
le problème des cours d'école c'est que
c'est un
c'est un impasser à la fois pédagogique
et programmatique pédagogique parce que
il n'y a pas de projet pédagogique en se
disant la cour d'école est un lieu dans
lequel on peut apprendre des choses et
c'est un impensé programmatique parce
que lorsqu'on programme la construction
d'une cour d'école le parent pauvre se
lit sur lequel on
n'a aucune exigence c'est
malheureusement la cour d'école donc on
voilà donc laisser a eu on est appelé
pour agir sur malheureusement ce qui est
déjà fait mais on intervient aussi c'est
le cas dans les Pyrénées-Atlantiques où
le département nous a demandé de venir
les aider sur la question du genre dans
l'espace public qui est aussi un sujet
très important dans les camps d'école
puisque les condécoles on s'en est rendu
compte favorise énormément les jeux de
garçons le jeu central qui met en
périphérie des filles et un lieu de de
survalorisation des garçons par rapport
aux filles enfin voilà c'est déjà le
premier lieu dans lequel il y a un vrai
problème de de d'équité et d'égalité des
sexes et donc on les a aidés à la fois
analyser sur certains sur certains
collèges ce qui se passait évidemment en
premier lieu avec les pratiquants que
sont les collégiens et puis évidemment
avec les autres les autres avec les
adultes évidemment les encadrants mais
aussi des personnels d'entretien parce
que ils ont une influence relativement
forte sur la manière dont est composé
une une cour d'école et donc ensemble
c'est concertations ont permis de
produire
des nouvelles images de ce qui était
attendu dans les camps d'écoles et
parallèlement on a construit aussi un
une aide pour aider le département dans
ces programmations futures à tenir
compte de l'intérêt de programmer en
avance d'exiger en avance les qualités
attendues des cours d'école mais
évidemment le sujet principal c'est ce
sont les cours déjà existantes alors
c'est beaucoup le rural parce que
évidemment les ciao sont contactés par
les par tout type de collectivités mais
c'est surtout les commune qui nous
appelle qui ont en effet un déficit de
d'ingénierie en interne et
la manière dont
les trois quarts des cours d'école dans
lesquels on va ça ressemble quand même
beaucoup plus à un parking de
supermarché que réellement un lieu de
pédagogie dans lequel on va apprendre ce
qu'est vivant dans lequel on va pouvoir
s'épanouir et les études pourtant les
études
scientifiques ont montré que une cour
d'école qui est très végétalisée est une
cour d'école dans laquelle les enfants
se sentent beaucoup mieux du coup sont
beaucoup plus concentrés à l'École etc
mais il y a aussi des problèmes de santé
publique puisque il y a une étude qui a
enfin été faite sur la nature de la
sfalte et la manière dont il se comporte
quand il se réchauffe et qui montre que
la salte dégage des des composés
organiques volatils dangereux pour la
santé au-delà de 30 degrés ce qui est
quand même pas beaucoup et quand on sait
que les enfants ont quand même le nez
encore plus bas que nous on voit les
problèmes que ça peut poser et on se
rend compte ainsi que les cours d'école
en fait sont dessinés par et pour les
adultes c'est-à-dire que l'obsession
première des adultes c'est la
surveillance la sécurité l'entretien et
malheureusement le l'épanouissement des
enfants n'entre pas en ligne de compte
dans la manière dont on dessine une cour
et il court elle participe aussi aux
économies d'énergie parce qu'évidemment
qui dit asphalte dit surchauffe donc
îlot
urbain qui va se répercuter évidemment à
l'intérieur des des bâtiments et
évidemment quand on apporte de la
fraîcheur avec la végétation on apporte
aussi de la fraîcheur à l'intérieur donc
tout ça est intimement lié et
laissé a eu lieu encore une fois avec
les autres partenaires parce que j'ai
entendu évidemment le président de de la
dune évoquée tout son travail alors moi
il travaille aussi beaucoup avec le ciao
du Puy-de-Dôme ils sont dans les mêmes
locaux ils avaient fait un document très
intéressant qui s'appelait le guide
urbanisme énergie donc voilà donc les
ciao sont aussi des incendiés pour aller
chercher différents partenaires le
réseau flamme c'est aussi des gens avec
qui
on travaille mais c'est c'est vrai que
la cour d'école est vraiment de parent
pauvre alors que ça devrait être un peu
le un peu le centre en tout cas pour
sensibiliser à la transition énergétique
et surtout écologique extrêmement
nécessaire et certains communs certaines
communes ont pris conscience aussi dans
le cadre du de des des difficultés qu'on
a eues avec la covid que finalement ces
cours d'école quand elles ressemblait
plus à un éden qu'un parking de
supermarché pouvait être aussi un lieu
en dehors des temps scolaires dans
lequel on pouvait aller à par plaisir
comme un mini parc au sein de au sein du
de la collectivité merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup le temps est compté je rappelle
néanmoins pour les orateurs suivants que
la mission est centrée sur le bâti
scolaire
que la cour d'école s'est importante
mais c'est quand même le bâti scolaire
qui est l'objet essentiel de la mission
que nous conduisons monsieur
c'est marqué là Monsieur Hans si vous
invite à prendre la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
bonjour mesdames et messieurs
d'abord vous dire combien on est nous
dans cette petite armée de la rénovation
on est on est 120 ingénieurs chercheurs
sur la dimension énergie environnement
et pour mener l'approche globale on est
250 c'est un premier commentaire
c'est-à-dire qu'on est relativement peu
en fait pour de la Recherche et
Développement ceci dit on se focalise
sur comment impacter sur le terrain ce
que l'on veut nous c'est que nos travaux
servent et on a bien vu tout l'intérêt
de ça dans les premières présentations
vous avez posé la question du
recrutement pour nous la rénovation
c'est une question de données confiance
et de donner envie il faut que les gens
aient envie de rénover et quand ils se
lancent il faut qu'ils aient confiance
dans ce qui va se passer il faut aussi
donner envie à des gens de nous
rejoindre pour rénover nous on pense
aussi qu'il faut des outils et on s'est
positionné à cet endroit là nous allons
outiller les gens des meilleurs outils
possibles pour les rendre en capacité à
minimale d'être plus efficace à défaut
d'être plus nombreux pour le moment
je voudrais aussi commencer par une
petite précision nous sortons d'un
travail important sur la oui je vous en
prie quand vous voulez outiller outiller
des outils des méthodes des outils
diagnostiques j'y reviendrai dans ma
présentation mais c'est de leur mettre à
disposition des moyens qui leur rendent
le travail plus rapidement c'est parfait
si j'ai la présentation c'est formidable
ça me permet aussi de vous montrer des
jolies cartes on était très heureux de
pouvoir vous les montrer je commence
avec la feuille de route des carbonation
monsieur le Président parce que on n'a
pas parlé des missions de gaz à effet de
serre depuis le début si nous rénovons
le bâti scolaire c'est bien sûr dans une
approche globale il y a du confort il y
a de la sécurité il y a du respect des
normes il y a la consommation d'énergie
et le les baisses des gaz à effet de
serre je rappelle que ce que nous dit la
feuille de route de décarbonation c'est
que nous avons
150 millions de tonnes émises par la
construction 100 millions pour repérer
le parc existant mais tout de même 50
millions pour fabriquer des produits de
construction nécessaires à la
construction neuve et à la rénovation
plus je rénove plus j'aimais des gaz à
effet de serre par les produits de
construction j'utilise 30 aujourd'hui
pour le 9
20 millions pour la rénovation dans le
choix de mes produits de construction il
faudra nécessairement intégrer ça je
pense qu'il faut le rappeler en
introduction
le premier des bouleaux pour nous c'est
de cibler nos démarches de rénovation je
vais avoir une approche très globale
dans un premier temps je vais pas vous
parler de batterie scolaire tout de
suite mais je voulais vous montrer vous
pouvez passer à la Slice suivante et
tout de suite à la suivante on est
d'abord sur cibler on voulait vous
parler de la base de données nationales
des bâtiments parce que la réaliser
aussi en partenariat le cerema est
impliqué aussi là dedans c'est tout
simple cet outil c'est vous avez vu les
deux cartes précédentes qui vous
montrent les matériaux de construction
qui vous montrent les années de
construction on sait dire aujourd'hui
grâce à cette base tout simplement parce
qu'elle regroupe l'ensemble des bases de
données actuellement disponibles croisés
spatialement regrouper un peu
d'intelligence artificielle pour
reproduire les données qui nous manquent
un peu d'enrichissement parce que par
exemple aujourd'hui si vous voulez bien
passer à la slide suivante et bien tout
simplement les DPE réelles que j'ai sur
le terrain c'est 20% des logements mais
aujourd'hui en fait je peux avoir 100%
des logements tout simplement parce que
les données disponibles je peux lancer
des simulations qui me permettent
d'avoir les mêmes informations
si je sais reimuler mon parc existence
et tout nouveau je sais simulé tout le
parc existant alors je sais dire en
fonction de tel ou telle stratégie de
rénovation combien je peux gagner je
vais vous montrer ça sur la slide
suivante
vous voyez ici encore une fois je m'en
excuse je suis pour l'instant
résidentiel mais je vais revenir avec le
rapprochement sur le tertiaire ne vous
inquiétez pas vous voyez qu'ici on a un
gisement
d'économie de carbone de 50 millions de
tonnes sur le parc existant tout
simplement parce qu'on connaît l'état
existant avec des simulations de DPE
mais je peux aussi simuler ce qui se
passe si je les rénove globalement vous
voyez dans les choses contre intuitives
par exemple c'est les logements occupés
par leurs propriétaires qui représentent
le plus gros gisement par exemple de
rénovation dans le résidentiel alors
pourquoi je vous montre ça je veux bien
s'il vous plaît la taille de suivante
merci beaucoup vous voyez par exemple
une information importante 20% du parc
résidentiel construire représente 50%
des gisements et grâce à la base de
données nationales des bâtiments on a
les adresses de ces bâtiments là donc on
sait où agir et on peut commencer par
cela ça nous dispensera de nous dire que
d'un certain dans des patrimoines
compliqués l'isolation par l'intérieur
ou extérieure pas possible etc je veux
bien que vous passiez au slide suivant
pour que je rentre dans le vif du sujet
bien sûr ce qui vous intéresse c'est le
bâti et les établissements scolaires
dans ce projet là nous travaillons avec
l'ADEME qui gère la base opéra et nous
souhaitons nous y travaillons ensemble
avec eux intégrer la base opéra au
dispositif donc la base opéra c'est ce
qui va nous permettre de récupérer les
données du décret éco énergie tertiaire
à partir du moment où ces données là
vont rentrer or c'est effectivement
depuis quelques mois les données
rentrent avec grand volume tout ce que
je viens de vous montrer sur le
résidentiel on sait de faire sur le parc
de Baptiste scolaire je veux bien la
slide de suivante s'il vous plaît alors
j'ai fait des petites choses dans un
coin de table avec la base opéra juste
vous dire qu'en gros on connaît ce parc
là on a des données pour dire à quoi il
est chauffé combien il consomme je veux
bien qu'on montre la slide suivante il
est assez rapidement par zone thermique
pour le primaire le secondaire le
supérieur par par zone géographique je
commence à pouvoir zoomer sur qui
consomme quoi donc si j'ai des épaves
thermiques dans ce parc là je peux aider
aussi la collectivité à dire c'est ce
collège là par lequel vous venez de
démarrer on vient de le faire pour
information sur le parc national des
piscines suite au grande résilience pour
le suite à la guerre en Ukraine c'est
donc la même démarche mais cette
démarche de ciblage elle est
fondamentale puisqu'on manque on manque
de d'acteurs pour rénover autant se
mettre sur les bâtiments qui sont les
plus les plus importants ça c'est la
première démarche pour nous c'est
fondamentales c'est de cibler je vais
bien qu'on passe au slide suivant s'il
vous plaît le deuxième sujet c'est
d'accompagner les projets alors ça a été
dit pas tous les personnes précédentes
bien sûr la logique c'est une approche
globale je veux bien qu'on nous montre
la slide suivante on essaye
d'accompagner les gens pour vous dire
notre comité scientifique nous a dit
vous avez fait ça vous avez accompagné
les collèges du Var mais vous êtes très
très loin de votre activité de recherche
de développement la suite nous a prouvé
que non c'est qu'en fait sur le terrain
aujourd'hui c'est nouveau de faire ça un
diagnostic multicritaire des simulations
des constructions de scénariste c'est un
peu nouveau je vais vous montrer très
rapidement vous allez comprendre c'est
simple mais je crois que ça a été dit
mais ça illustre aussi notre capacité
collectivement à outiller des gens sur
le terrain slide suivant s'il vous plaît
tout simplement avec les acteurs de
terrain avec les gens qui occupent ces
bâtiments scolaires mais aussi avec les
maîtres d'ouvrage on a défini avec eux
dans une logique multicritère qu'est-ce
qui est important pour vous de
travailler dans votre projet en qualité
de vie en risque en économie de
ressources sur le slide suivant vous
allez vous apercevoir et ça peut être
une surprise mais vous voyez que dans le
cas des collèges du Var finalement la
remise en conformité qui est une grande
une grande nécessité pour eux alors je
veux bien qu'on passe très rapidement
sur les deux transparents suivants juste
pour vous dire qu'on sait arriver vous
voyez à les accompagner avec des outils
relativement simple qu'on pourrait
mettre sur les terrains à disposition
des acteurs qui sont là nous c'est pas à
nous de trouver on ne devrait jamais
être là en revanche être là avec ces
outils là pour pouvoir établir des
bouquets de travaux et dire bah voilà en
fait sur les différents critères qui
vous intéressent voilà où est votre
projet voilà typiquement le type de
travail collectif qu'on préconise parce
que ces outils là s'ils sont pas connus
sur le terrain c'est vraiment dommage
alors pourquoi je vous parle de la base
de données nationales des bâtiments ce
que vous évoquez le maquis mais je suis
complètement en ligne avec monsieur
Berto c'est un maki parce qu'on n'a pas
la carte mais aujourd'hui sur la base de
données nationales des bâtiments si
j'arrive et que c'est une maison
individuelle je peux vous mettre un
outil d'audit pour les maisons
individuelles si j'identifie que c'est
un bâtiment de colle primaire je peux
vous mettre un outil d'audit spécifique
à l'école primaire il est facile à
trouver puisque je viens d'aller sur la
base de données nationales des bâtiments
saisir cette adresse là et donc l'outil
il vous remonte de manière dynamique
c'est vraiment sur mesure en fait on
peut plus trop se tromper et l'ensemble
des acteurs que nous sommes pouvons
mettre des données et je l'espère que
nos collègues derrière remettront les
données de mesure de performance qu'ils
auront sur le terrain pour le remonter
le dernier point fondamental monsieur le
Président après avoir ciblé et
accompagné c'est de sécuriser les
performances nous avons un graphe
problème dans la construction en général
les pathologies sont nombreuses je
disais que la R&D c'était faible à un
05% du chiffre d'affaires de la
construction les pathologies 10 à 15 %
et les performances énergétiques sont
moyennement dedans pour la plupart il
faut rentrer dans une culture du
résultat je voudrais vous montrer sur le
slice suivant c'est intéressant
l'Observatoire des contrats de
performance énergétiques qui sont des
contrats très clairement vise à
sécuriser tout ça vous voyez très
rapidement que sur les 380 CPE qui ont
été réalisés depuis 2007 120 sont en
réalité des bâtiments scolaires donc
c'est la grosse majorité de ces de ces
projets là vous les voyez des lycées des
départements des collèges pardon des
écoles primaires et puis de des
bâtiments d'enseignement supérieur et
d'université il est fondamental de
s'inscrire dans cette démarche là
regardez nos collègues également et
anglais qui s'interrogent d'avoir
injecté beaucoup d'argent sur de la
rénovation sans en voir les résultats il
est fondamental de mener ce type de
contrat de performance énergétique qui
ne sont plus de la recherche mais aussi
de continuer des travaux je vais vous
montrer le slide suivant quelque chose
qui malheureusement n'est pas
opérationnel mais que nous développons
avec le CRMA en ce moment sur la maison
individuelle ce sont le genre de méthode
qu'il faudra probablement déployer sur
le terrain sur une maison individuelle
aujourd'hui de manière opérationnelle
vous faites venir une camionnette vous
instrumentez la maison après rénovation
et 24 heures plus tard on vous dit si
oui ou non les travaux de rénovation ont
été correctement réalisées avant que
l'occupant revienne ou pendant qu'il est
parti en week-end selon il est
fondamental de s'organiser vers une
garantie de performance on aura
autrement on aura une déconvenue quant à
l'argent investi voilà pour les
principaux messages du CSTB je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup
il nous reste
il nous reste pour conclure ce premier
tour
monsieur Rodriguez de l'Institut
français pour la performance énergétique
du bâtiment ainsi que Madame Nathalie
Lederman
très bien
merci monsieur le Président non je suis
en présentiel
bonjour à toutes et à tous je suis
Christophe Rodriguez
merci de nous avoir convié aujourd'hui
pour vous parler d'un jeu puisque les
concours cubes sont effectivement une
démarche ludique pour gamifier un petit
peu cette logique de sobriété elle fait
mon anime depuis de nombreuses années
des concours d'économie d'énergie et on
est très heureux d'avoir noué un certain
nombre de partenariats dont un
partenaire que le cerema il y a plus de
3 ans à présent pour imaginer une
déclinaison de ses concours pour les
collèges et les lycées et on est très
heureux aujourd'hui d'avoir le soutien
de la snccr pour aller à l'aventure des
écoles le principe des concours cubes
les bénéfices et les aussi les freins on
a pu constater sur le terrain c'est tout
l'objet de notre témoignage
d'aujourd'hui le principe est assez
simple finalement on se donne une année
pour activer le maximum d'actions
d'économies d'énergie rapide voilà donc
on est vraiment sur des temps de retour
extrêmement courts on est sur toute la
thématique de la sobriété qui nous a
animé depuis un an et demi à présent et
finalement on va faire la mesure la
vérification de cette performance la
magie du concours cube est le muscle en
fait c'est plusieurs éléments le premier
c'est de repositionner au cœur de la
préoccupation de chacune des parties
prenantes la mesure de la consommation
réelle ça c'est vraiment le muscle c'est
ce qui fait que le concours marche et
donc en fait on part du postulat à
partir du moment où on met en visibilité
du personnel technique de la
collectivité des enseignants des élèves
l'information de la consommation
d'énergie des économies qui ont été
réalisées et des leviers les gens ont un
nombre incroyable d'idées et
d'initiatives qui vont permettre d'aller
chercher la performance énergétique donc
le meilleur plan d'action c'est pas
forcément celui qu'on imagine avec des
jumelles de loin finalement les
utilisateurs du bâtiment ils n'attendent
que ça ce sont des citoyens quand ils
rentrent chez eux et les élèves on le
verra tout à l'heure quand il rentre
chez eux ils ont aussi envie de faire
avancer les choses donc c'est ça
vraiment la magie du concours cube on
peut petite citer par exemple les
diagnostics participatifs qui sont
animés par le céréma le principe et le
suivant on va aller dans un dans un dans
un collège par exemple dans une école et
avec l'ensemble des parties prenantes
personnels techniques encore une fois
enseignant on va faire prendre
conscience à l'ensemble des partis
prenantes qui a des leviers qui a des
choses qui peuvent être faites pour
aller chercher des économies d'énergie
donc voilà vraiment c'est l'ADN du
concours quels sont les bénéfices déjà
se dire que ça marche on sait que ça
fonctionne depuis le début de
l'animation du concours on obtient en
moyenne entre 10 et 15 % d'économie
d'énergie aujourd'hui cubes c'est 923
bâtiments collèges lycée sans école
maintenant et c'est plus de 65
collectivités qui sont embarquées dans
la dynamique on sait que les économies
sont au rendez-vous et on peut par
exemple faire un clin d'oeil au collège
Val de Rance en Bretagne qui a fait
l'année dernière 23% 30% 31% d'économie
de gaz à effet de serre donc je parle
quand même de gaz à effet de serre du
coup c'était pour faire un trait d'union
et donc et donc on sait que ça
fonctionne l'autre bénéfice du concours
d'économie bien sûr n'hésitez pas
bien compris c'est une forme de
convention citoyenne
avant l'heure excellent usagers tout à
fait alors en fait le principe du
principe du concours une collectivité va
par exemple s'inscrire dans le concours
avec un certain nombre de sites collèges
école lycée et en fait les sites vont
s'engager dans une démarche collective
pour activer toutes les actions
possibles de réglage de réglage de
température d'optimisation technique des
cogestes voilà on va apprendre ensemble
à quels sont mes leviers comment est-ce
que je peux modifier la température
éteindre la lumière et nous en fait on
les accompagne en partenariat avec le
serema pour mieux comprendre les enjeux
énergétiques il y a des animations etc
et en fait on leur met en visibilité
dans une démarche ludique des
classements c'est-à-dire que tous les
mois ils vont voir l'information du
classement ou en Suisse etc en terme de
oui
vous voyez dans cette salle on pourrait
très bien ouvrir les fenêtres ou mettre
des occultants qui laisse passer la
lumière et au contraire éteindre tous
ces spots vous faites ça vous faites une
économie d'énergie importante et bien ce
qui se passe dans les écoles c'est que
les gamins ils vous disent des trucs
comme ça c'est aussi bête que ça
voilà
est-ce que ça répond à votre question ce
que moi c'est un peu direct mais c'est
c'est du bon sens oui mais en réalité et
on le voit à la fois dans les écoles on
le voit à la fois dans les dans les
entreprises sur le programme cube c'est
vraiment de faire travailler les gens et
là en l'occurrence les élèves sur moi
j'ai assisté personnellement un certain
nombre de séances c'est incroyable si
vous voulez gamins ils disent mais
attendez là il y a trois rangées de
lumière ça serait aussi bien si on en
laissait que deux allumés
c'est des choses basiques et rien
qu'avec ça alors après derrière c'est
voilà le réglage de la chaudière machin
les enseignants font un projet
pédagogique autour et vous arrivez rien
qu'avec ça entre 10 et 25% d'économie
d'énergie
ce qui est quand même assez incroyable
c'est quand même incroyable c'est tout à
fait significatif donc en fait il y a
vraiment de nombreux bénéfices parce
qu'elle vient de le mentionner il y a
effectivement cette réappropriation
finalement des sujets énergétiques le
concours a aussi une vertu c'est de
créer finalement un nouveau cadre de
collaboration entre des parties
prenantes qui se sont sépare forcément
appliquées sur le sujet de l'énergie
donc on s'aperçoit en fait que à la fin
de la démarche du concours souvent les
gens ont envie d'aller plus loin donc ça
peut être aussi une extraordinaire
passerelle pour s'engager de façon
beaucoup plus importante sur par exemple
des travaux ou une rénovation profonde
on a réussi à embarquer l'ensemble des
parties prenantes donc d'un seul coup
peut-être qu'on est prêt à aller
beaucoup plus loin et c'est ça tout
l'objectif du concours la boîte à idées
collective
le postulat du travail c'est que ceux
qu'on est meilleures idées c'est ceux
qui sont dans le bâtiment toute la
journée
en plus ils le font et on mesure quand
même
je sais pas s'il y aura des arrêts de
jeu à la fin mais je vais quand même
essayer de tenir les 10 minutes
totalement le sujet très bien du coup il
y a un autre bénéfice qu'on souhaitait
explorer on s'est posé la question mais
finalement le soir quand les élèves
rentrent à la maison et qui nous ont
toute la journée donné tout un tas de
bonnes idées pour faire des économies
d'énergie et ce qui tire pas la main je
leurs parents en disant papa maman
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas aussi se
mettre dans une démarche de sobriété à
la maison et donc on a mené une étude et
Nathalie je te donne la main pour nous
présenter un petit peu les résultats de
cette étude oui juste en fait c'est
comme 300000 aujourd'hui qu'on
participait au minimum à cube quoi donc
c'est vraiment des gens qui ont des
élèves qui ont réfléchi au sujet et en
fait le l'étude qu'on a fait on a fait
cette étude avec Harris Interactive des
psychosociologues et des et une étude
aussi interne au niveau technique et
donc on a été étonné et bluffé par les
par les résultats en fait 80 pour 11%
des élèves qui ont fait cubes à l'école
transfert leur nouveau savoir à la
maison
11% des élèves vont parler de transition
écologique vont parler d'économie
d'énergie de gaz à effet de serre à
leurs parents et les parents derrière
parce qu'on a aussi interrogé les
parents 87% des parents chez qui les
transferts agissent sur ce sujet donc on
voit qu'un vrai ils font attention à la
maison aussi alors on leur donne des
petits guides etc puisqu'il y a une
sorte de kit ambassadeur ils vont faire
attention à la maison aux usages et ils
vont aussi mettre en place des
rénovations et on voit qu'un et on a
mesuré en fait les économies d'énergie
réellement faite en leur a demandé leur
mandat au leur demander d'avoir accès
aux factures de d'énergie dans les dans
les foyers on se rend compte qu'il y a
eu 11% d'économies d'énergie et c'était
avant le plan de sobriété donc c'est ces
chiffres ils sont incroyables quoi enfin
moi je trouve ça c'est
c'est tout nouveau l'étude elle est pas
encore complètement sortie c'est
vraiment vous avez la restitution en
amont parce qu'on a on n'a pas encore
fait de conférence de conférence dessus
mais voilà on voulait vous puisqu'on en
avait rendez-vous et on vous en remercie
on s'était dit qu'on allait vous parler
de ces petits chiffres qui sont vraiment
très intéressants extraordinaire parce
qu'en fait elle révèle une intuition
coupe d'avion c'est-à-dire qu'on avait
que cube c'est à la fois un programme
avec une dimension un peu technique mais
c'est des économies d'énergie donc
financières à la clé mais aussi un
programme pédagogique ou finalement on a
des citoyens de demain qui sont en train
de s'approprier le sujet de la
transition environnementale et là avec
cette étude là quelque part on est
capable de mettre des chiffres on sait
que ça fonctionne quand il rentre à la
maison on a des effets collatéraux qui
sont tout à fait intéressants alors au
travers du programme cube on voit aussi
un certain nombre de frein sur le
terrain qu'on souhaitait mettre en
relief et là Nathalie je te laisse alors
c'est vrai que d'abord il faut faire
connaître le programme on a 923
établissements 65 collectivités c'est
pas mal mais c'est pas assez on pourrait
en faire plus et d'ailleurs grâce
aujourd'hui à acté on continue à être
financé puisque ce programme était
financé par les C2 donc c'était
intéressant parce
à l'époque et maintenant ça va ça va ça
va un peu ça va continuer la
collectivité devait inscrire le
département aux régions 6 établissements
payés l'inscription des établissements
1000 euros pour les collèges
et maintenant ça va être 2000 euros pour
les collèges et on recevait des C2E à
peu près 10000 euros pour faire tout le
programme donc c'est un programme
financé donc mais c'était très
intéressant parce que si vous voulez un
collège aujourd'hui
si il fait 10% d'économies d'énergie il
va gagner en moyenne 5600 euros je parle
des prix d'énergie il y a deux ans je
parle pas des parce que maintenant on
comprend plus on comprend plus rien on
prit l'énergie je parle que j'avais
avant mais après les proportions on
essaye mais on fait 10% d'économie
d'énergie la collectivité va gagner 5500
euros par collège donc payer 1000 euros
c'est pas grand chose si vous voulez là
elle va payer peut-être 2000 euros avec
le nouveau programme et c'est toujours
pas grand chose maintenant moi j'avais
l'impression de leur faire un cadeau
quand je les appelais les collectivités
j'en ai mais attendez moi je connais
aucun
sujet on a un roi aussi important de moi
je me placerai toutes mes économies si
je pouvais avoir quelque chose de cet
ordre là il me disait oui mais vous avez
tout à fait raison etc mais c'est pas
les mêmes services faut en parler le
service patrimoine le service financier
bref il y a quand même une multitude de
services dans les collectivités qui font
que parfois c'est un peu c'est ça ça on
met un temps à la décision mais on y
arrive mais je voulais juste te dire ça
parce que c'est important le point
numéro 2 sur les données de consommation
je le développe et puis je te laisserai
le mot de la fin ok le deuxième point
important c'est que on a énormément de
mal à récupérer les données de
consommation ce qui est quand même le
cœur un peu du réacteur du concours et
d'ailleurs des fois je fais un trait la
magie du concours cube c'est que les
gens retrouvent leur facture et l'air de
rien quand on a retrouvé sa facture d'un
seul coup on prend conscience et une
fois qu'on a pris conscience on prend
des initiatives on s'engage et donc
c'est le début d'une aventure donc ça
c'est aussi un point de vigilance c'est
à dire effectivement les gens qui
peuvent agir n'ont pas forcément
conscience de la consommation il paye
pas forcément la facture et ça c'est un
vrai sujet profond qui a quand même un
peu le point de départ de toute cette
aventure puis peut-être le dernier point
je te laisse le mot il est vrai que
notamment les directeurs
d'établissements souvent ils ne savent
pas combien ils payent donc moi comment
on peut demander à quelqu'un de faire
des économies si on sait pas combien on
paye et ça c'est systématique donc déjà
le fait de savoir d'avoir les montants
ça permet les enseignants aussi étaient
très étonnés des des
montants qu'il payait et donc justement
il y en a qui ont une très bonne idée
c'est que il y a des départements qui
qui ont dit alors à leurs établissements
ben écoutez si vous faites des économies
d'énergie nous on va vous donner une
partie des économies qu'on va faire sur
vos établissements ils leur ont fait une
dotation alors pas la dotation complète
mais peut-être 10% des économies qu'ils
ont faites pour faire un voyage pour
faire quelque chose en fait une dotation
et donc ils ont aussi là dessus
motivée donc les
c'est que on s'est rendu compte que les
collectivités réengagées d'autres
établissements scolaires puisque la
première année ils engagent pas tous que
il y avait un lien entre les services
qui se qui se faisaient qui étaient très
intéressants souvent même dans les
collectivités on se rend compte que le
service patrimoine va il travaille pas
tellement avec le service éducation nous
ça nous permet de les mettre autour de
la table et de réfléchir ensemble en
fait c'est l'intelligence collective
mais à partir du moment où les gens sont
autour de la table ils réfléchissent et
ça avance les économies sont en
rendez-vous les établissements
recommandent pubs à leur père il y a
aussi quelque chose alors ça on s'était
pas notre objectif à la base mais c'est
un renforcement de la citoyenneté des
élèves c'est à dire que les élèves du
coup ils comprend aussi comment
fonctionne les collectivités ils se
sentent beaucoup plus citoyens et ça je
trouve que pour l'avenir de notre pays
c'est vraiment important et moi je tiens
à ça donc la citoyenneté des élèves je
trouve que c'est très important il faut
qu'il vote bientôt bientôt
et donc aussi un intérêt éducatif du
mode projet ça c'est ce que nous dit
l'éducation nationale puisqu'on bien sûr
on travaille avec les deux ministères à
l'éducation nationale et ministère de la
transition écologique et le côté de
projets éducatifs ça implique aussi
beaucoup d'élèves ça récupère des élèves
qui sont décrocheurs parce qu'ils
travaillent autour d'un sujet qui est
connexe enfin qui est transverse et qui
est hors des disciplines classiques mais
avec toutes les disciplines quand même
et ça aussi c'est très intéressant pour
les élèves et donc se transfert des
élèves pour les parents il y a un corps
plein de choses intéressantes mais les
10 minutes sont passées
[Rires]
vous pouvez nous donner quelques
exemples que
des exemples sur les alors sur les
établissements de chaque année si vous
voulez on a une quinzaine de prix donc
des prix de la meilleure économie
d'énergie alors par région par par lycée
par collège on a des prix des
meilleures diminutions de gaz à effet de
serre on a aussi des prix alors on a
fait aussi des prix du meilleur
événement de la meilleure intégration
pédagogique parce que faut les voir les
élèves ils font des flash mob ils font
des escaliers il faut des fêtes de
l'énergie mais c'est hallucinant
c'est-à-dire que un collège ou un lycée
cubes on le voit tout de suite on rentre
dedans on voit des affiches partout des
nudes on voit des vélos les dans les
lycées professionnels ils construisent
des vélos avec des batteries pour
recharger les portables en fait
cette manière de voir cette méthodologie
elle peut tout à fait transposée à
d'autres
vous parliez de l'heure d'élection
est-ce que on pourrait motiver les
électeurs à justement
30 secondes parce que
j'étais c'est à dire qu'on va lancer on
peut en parler aujourd'hui on va lancer
on va lancer un cube ville en fait pour
justement motiver en fait c'est tous les
agents municipaux qui vont inscrire les
bâtiments communaux et en fait ils vont
pouvoir aussi tester ce principe on
s'est rendu compte que dans les
entreprises ça marchait très bien en
fait il faut des équipes transverses
faut pas que ça vienne de la hiérarchie
faut pas de note de service etc faut que
des gens d'une manière tout à fait
transverse s'empare du sujet et à partir
du moment où les agents municipaux vont
s'emparer du sujet dans leur bâtiment
ils vont après tout à fait naturellement
en fait transférer ce sujet auprès des
citoyens mais encore il faut donner la
première chose je pense que c'est de
donner l'exemple prends beaucoup à la
théorie la goutte d'eau effectivement
l'exemple de pédagogie par exemple et
c'est ça qui est extrêmement intéressant
qui nous a séduit dans la proche des
concours cube dans leur ensemble jusqu'à
créer un nouveau concours effectivement
vous avez l'exclusivité aujourd'hui
maintenant sont réserves ces éléments
pour la présente quelques jours
effectivement d'élargir la réflexion qui
a prouvé son intérêt dans les bâtiments
éducatifs collège lycée école maintenant
à l'ensemble des bâtiments de la
collectivité vous avez des concours
aussi qui existent dans une autre
approche pour famille à énergie positive
notamment dans le logement des choses
comme ça qui peuvent être un peu le
pendant dans le côté plus logements
citoyen en tant que tel on s'intéresse
évidemment aux agents de la collectivité
des collectivités un de tous types de la
commune à l'intercool à la métropole etc
de manière à apporter l'action effective
sur les consommations la collectivité
mais aussi effectivement avec cet effet
levier extrêmement intéressant dans les
familles et dans l'environnement de
l'agent donc on arrive à convertir comme
ça goutte d'eau plus goutte d'eau un
ensemble de mer assez large au niveau
des collectivités
de lever la main quand on veut prendre
la parole moi je l'ai appris et je
respecte Monsieur Merci beaucoup ce sera
très court et tant pis si c'est
enregistré pour les petits moments de
honte pour le CSTB mais nous sommes
inscrits au concours cube il y a 5 ans à
ma prise de fonction sur l'établissement
de Grenoble ça s'est passé exactement
comme Madame Lederman là
on s'inscrit maintenant faut regarder il
faut retrouver nos factures il faut
faire les choses on a été médaille de
bronze ça c'est pour la partie
sympathique le pourquoi on a été
médaille de bronze parce que nous nous
sommes aperçus en tout cas les équipes
techniques se sont aperçues que nous
n'avions pas de régulateur et de
programmateur sur sur 1000 m² de
bâtiment chauffés à l'électricité donc
évidemment quand on arrête de chauffer
le soir et le week-end on fait des
économies considérables donc encore une
fois si ça arrive au STB dans ses
bureaux je pense que ça ça arrivera à
beaucoup de gens donc juste pour vous
redire à quel point on croit beaucoup à
la démarche qui est proposée
merci beaucoup en tout cas je sais pas
si on aura le temps je vous donne la
parole mais ça m'aurait intéressé
d'aller voir ça avec les pieds dans une
mais le temps passe vite et nous sommes
déjà au mois d'avril oui on verra on
verra
mais simplement pour compléter
l'information pour vous dire qu'on
travaille également avec
à la fois Christophe Béchu et sa dislas
Guérini a fabriqué un cube état qui
devrait pas tarder à être annoncé
portant sur les 100 000 bâtiments de
l'État
donc voilà non non mais voilà donc ça
c'est alors bon j'ai pas devancé
l'annonce du ministre mais mais voilà
enfin clairement effectivement le
process s'intéresse plus des travaux sur
les logements en même temps avec les
fèves
ce qui est sûr c'est que tout le monde
trouve que ça marche bien quoi
vous avez tout à l'heure parler de
d'évoquer les récompenses les carottes
que vous proposiez aux enseignants en
cas d'économie d'énergie est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner un exemple et sur
quel degré quelle importance ont porté
ses économies alors les économies en
fait
ce sont les départements en fait là en
l'occurrence c'était des départements je
crois que c'était le département de
l'Yonne c'est même noir est bonne qui
avait justement proposé et celui des
Côtes d'Armor aussi qui avait redonné
une sorte de dotation puisque en fait ce
qui est important aussi de savoir c'est
que les départements et les
établissements scolaires parfois c'est
les établissements scolaires qui payent
directement les factures d'énergie et
parfois c'est les départements quoi
qu'il en soit quand c'est les
établissements scolaires c'est les
départements qui leur donnent une
dotation et donc là en l'occurrence il
leur donnait leur donner une dotation
supplémente enfin une dotation pour pour
faire d'autres choses dans
l'établissement puisqu'ils avaient fait
des économies sur ces établissements bon
c'est des choses comme ça qui se font
c'est arrivé dans deux à ma connaissance
dans deux départements mais c'est
quelque chose d'intéressant je trouve de
enfin ça pourrait être intéressant de en
tout cas on en parle on en fait des fois
des réunions avec tous les départements
qui ont participé et chacun donne ses
idées et voilà c'est des choses qui sont
intéressantes
la très grande récompense du concours en
fait c'est vraiment la fierté et le
plaisir que les gens prennent à part
participer au concours enfin donc c'est
vraiment ça qui recherchait par les gens
merci tout à l'heure on a parlé de la de
d'économes de flux et de construire une
énergie partagée quelle est la
différence entre
mesquidie différence il y a
pour être précis par leur être
complémentarité effectivement l'idée
quand on a développé le réseau des
économes de flux actées notamment et te
dire que les CEP ne couvraient pas la
totalité du territoire en l'occurrence
donc l'idée de mettre des ce pélo que
j'en avais pas via la figure de
l'économie de flux et là où il y avait
des CEP qui était plutôt orientés mais
ça c'est la proche locale qui va le
déterminer rémi a parlé de l'exemple
concret de ce qui se passait à la dune
notamment avec le partenariat historique
de l'agence et le fait d'être acté et
l'accompagnement spécifique sur les
écoles de compléter l'approche technique
par une approche économique de bouclage
de plan de financier de financement du
passage à l'acte
différents ou sur les mêmes territoires
de leur qui avait déjà effectivement des
personnes dédiée c'est ça c'est ça donc
ou bien sur les territoires où il y en
avait pas compléter le réseau le maillet
ou bien venir en complément sur des
territoires qui avaient déjà des CEP
c'est dans ce cas contraire de manière
très étroite avec l'ADEME lorsqu'on a
les collectivités qui nous demandent de
développer des postes économes de flux
on vérifie déjà s'il y a des sur le
territoire ce qui font exactement et
voir s'il y a lieu ou pas développer
l'aspect financier il faudrait que vous
recommenciez et que vous parliez que
vous vulgarisiez davantage je comprends
pas vraiment la différence donc vous
avez
dites-moi ce que ce que fait un économe
de flux un économe de flux acté dans son
poste
de manière générale mais acté dans le
cadre du programme que je porte
effectivement il a ce rôle de commencer
par faire l'état des lieux le tour du
bâti d'une collectivité pour réparer les
bâtiments dépervidditifs voilà un
constat une première analyse une analyse
de premier niveau en disant voilà là je
pressens qui va y avoir tel gisement
d'économie d'énergie sur le double
vitrage sur l'éclairage sur l'approche
d'usage la régulation etc de commencer
des conseils de premier niveau exemple
typique un bâtiment qui n'est pas réglé
on commence par mettre en place une
régulation on commence par retravailler
le métronome qui va calquer les
différents éléments d'éclairage jour
nuit par exemple il va aller jusqu'à
coller collectivités en ça vaut le coup
d'aller plus loin en lançant un vrai
audit énergétique il va analyser les
résultats avec le bureau d'études
toujours l'économes de flux l'économe de
flux ou le CEP aussi du coup sur cette
partie allemand qui se rejoignent dans
leur dans leur action au niveau des
territoires qui ont
peut-être fait soit par là soit par
l'autre absolument absolument c'est
juste la question du maillage
territorial qui va le déterminer ensuite
effectivement on va jusqu'à
la même fonction mais selon qu'on soit
sur tel territoire ou tel autre
territoire on appelle ça et que l'homme
de flux globalement c'est l'idée lorsque
effectivement il y a l'un n'est pas
présent sur le sur le territoire en
revanche quand il y a déjà un cep qui
est le réseau historique de l'ADEME
l'économe de flux lui va se concentrer
sur la partie bouclage de plan financier
des travaux comment est-ce qu'on va
parce que finalement
est fait par l'ADEME notamment
effectivement où l'économie de fusion
je vous donne la parole monsieur je vous
remercie
les conseillers en énergie partagée sont
partagées et c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui a été développé notamment pour
les collectivités qui n'avaient pas les
moyens de se développer de se donner des
moyens humains en gros si vous faites
schématiser très fort on pourrait dire
que l'économie de flux c'est un
conseiller en énergie et globalement
en ce consommation diverses au sein
d'une collectivité
et que le cancer de l'énergie partagée
c'est un peu la même chose mais partagez
entre un certain nombre de collectivités
après si vous me le permettez je
voudrais faire un tout petit commentaire
par rapport à très intéressant échange
qu'on avait tout à l'heure sur cube qui
est c'est sur la complémentarité des
démarches ont quand même en gros les
démarches qui permettent de mobiliser
comme on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure
et le personnel et les techniciens etc
etc autour de la question de la maîtrise
de l'énergie dans un bâtiment la plupart
du temps et enfin les actions les agar
appliques étaient évoqués tout à l'heure
ce sont des actions de sobriété
qui vont parfois avoir des résultats
extrêmement spectaculaires parfois un
peu moins mais qui n'épuise pas tout ce
qu'on peut faire pour baisser les
consommations de bâtiments puisque
derrière ces actions de sobriété ou en
gros on travaille sur les usages on
éteint les lumières etc
interviennent des actions rénovation
énergétique qui elle implique les
investissements je veux juste dire que
tout ceci est parfaitement
complémentaire mais
l'un des plus palourdes
merci beaucoup madame
Combre souhaitait s'exprimer également
[Musique]
sur l'ensemble des dispositifs qui ont
été déployés de rappeler juste que ces
dispositifs qui émanent donc d'organe
qui sont nationaux ont vraiment besoin
de relais locaux et de proximité pour
pouvoir relayer justement ce genre de
dispositif parce que la mise en oeuvre
est pas vraiment par la proximité voilà
donc c'était vraiment rappelé ça et que
aussi le chant du CEP lorsqu'il est
rattaché au sein d'une agence locale de
l'énergie et du climat il n'est pas
juste dans l'analyse des flux il est
aussi avec l'accompagnement d'une vision
beaucoup plus globale de l'ensemble de
tout ce qui tout ce qui s'agit qui sur
le champ de l'énergie et du climat c'est
à dire pas seulement sur la rénovation
mais aussi sur l'ensemble de
d'un diagnostic qui sera plus élargi à
l'échelle territoriale
est-ce que vous partagez le même
enthousiasme que votre collègue sur cube
moi je trouve que tous les dispositifs
qui vont dans le même sens sont très
bien forcément après voilà faut vraiment
relayer faut vraiment créer des
partenariats avec des personnes qui sont
très implantées pour pouvoir le porter
localement et le proposer aussi merci
Monsieur le stage
monsieur le Président non c'était pour
répondre à la question vous avez posé
concernant l'articulation la différence
entre les CEP économes de flux on sait
pas la première fois comme comme un
processus cette question bien évidemment
alors c'est des cousins qui sont très
proches tellement proche que cette
question
du coup j'ai essayé de me fendre d'une
note qui expliquait la différence entre
les deux et je me suis aperçu finalement
qu'il y avait plus de variations au sein
de chacun des deux réseaux qu'entre les
deux réseaux
donc en fait les CEP il c'est une
appellation mais derrière l'appellation
derrière une charte etc il y a quand
même la variabilité
et puis les écoles de flux c'est pareil
il y a une animation il y a une charte
il y a un logo il y a une variabilité
également il y a de variétés entre deux
écoles de flux actes donc finalement moi
j'ai j'ai baissé les bras je dis que
finalement c'est kif quoi voilà donc
appelons-le économe de flux appelons les
CEP toute façon il sort des mêmes écoles
voilà il y a des souples qui sont
devenus économes de flux pareil dans
l'autre sens donc
si vous dites que l'heure est égal à
l'autre c'est pas que c'est pas vraiment
vrai mais c'est pas complètement faux
non plus
ça me permettait effectivement je crois
que les deux interventions se rejoignent
c'est l'ingénierie c'est le local qui va
déterminer au final on propose un
récipient on propose nous un
co-financement clairement que ce soit
l'ADEME ou acté en l'occurrence sur la
figure de l'économie de flux ou CEP en
l'occurrence et après ce niveau local ou
la proprio de le faire entre un
territoire rural et un territoire urbain
ce sera pas la même approche il va y
avoir plus d'ingénierie dans le
territoire urbain donc l'économe de flux
sera peut-être sur l'amant le
recensement mais pas effectivement sur
la motrice d'ouvrage des travaux de
maîtrise ouvrages délégués ou autre dans
rural peut-être différemment et entre
dans le rural par exemple en Bretagne où
il y a le réseau des Alecs qui est
extrêmement développé et le Real peut
être plus sur d'autres endroits de la
France par exemple en pacao ou la
configuration haut ça va être deux types
d'acteurs qui vont se mettre en place
avec un autre type d'ingénierie et qui
vont s'approprier localement cette
figure de l'économe de flux et en juin
vraiment les interventions précédentes
sur la question de l'ingénierie
territoriale donc nous ce qu'on fait
c'est vraiment mettre à disposition le
cadre le carburant si je peux dire pour
agir en tant que tel charge ensuite aux
acteurs locaux de s'approprier ces
outils nationaux que sont support és par
l'ADEME et acté en l'occurrence de
manière à définir le meilleur rôle au
niveau local
je remets une pièce dans les idées que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure on a on a un
réseau sur le terrain ils sont tous
différents ils sont sans doute presque
tous pareils ce que l'on souhaite c'est
que notre parc progresse en
compréhension avant de se lancer dans
des travaux efficaces ce que je mesure
quotidiennement c'est que derrière c'est
quand même un peu ce que chacun veut
faire sur des terrains s'il y en a un
qui est sensibilisé à tel matériaux il
va pousser celle-là dans certains cas
faut se le dire on comprend pas pourquoi
du produit ça je pense que les fédérer
autour d'outils de diagnostic autour de
méthode qui nous permettent d'être sûr
de ce que l'on fait sur le terrain et
quelque chose qui contribuait à les
rassembler en fait et à se dire bah du
coup les diagnostics qui sont faits que
ce soit dans le Nord dans le sud en
Lorraine ou à Toulouse en fait on a on a
des méthodes qui et ça je pense qu'il
faut vraiment s'en occuper autrement la
nature ayant horreur du vide on voit une
multitude de petites initiatives qui se
prennent c'est chacun son outil à la fin
c'est pareil c'est comme pour les
diagnostiqueurs ils sont tous un et même
tous un petit peu différent et puis il
leur manque quelque chose en tout cas si
on avait pris le tout l'argent pour les
faire tous pour en faire un seul bien et
le propager on aurait fait des économies
substantielles donc nous on attire votre
attention là-dessus les acteurs de
terrain il faut les outils avec des
méthodes qui permettent aussi de faire
les bonnes analyses et je le redis sur
le carbone faisons attention sur les gaz
à effet de serre sur le terrain les gens
ne sont pas formés c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui potentiellement on
préconise des choses qui sont déjà plus
du tout ce qu'il faut faire et ça on l'a
mesuré tous les jours je pourrais vous
raconter dans les écoles d'architecture
ou les enseignants eux-mêmes nous ont
dit venez parler de carbone parce que
comme ça on va à culturer nos futurs
architectes c'est l'enseignant qui m'a
dit ah bah moi je leur disais jusqu'à
présent de construire léger ce serait
forcément bas carbone ce qui est pas
exactement suffisamment ce qu'il faut
faire donc moi je pense qu'il y a un
sujet là dessus il faut que s'assurer
que sur des terrains les gens soient
outillés par quelque chose de consolider
un peu en amont
je suis à la fois d'accord avec toi et à
la fois je vais mettre un petit bémol
pour être à la tête donc d'un
établissement avec en gros 2500
personnes la moitié d'ingénieurs
répartis un peu partout en France c'est
notre problème quotidien c'est à dire
comment arriver à un moment à
standardiser au maximum les méthodes etc
mais aussi comment ne pas tuer la
créativité et c'est ça cette difficulté
c'est qu'à la fois il faut bien sûr
outiller je suis d'accord avec ce que tu
dis et à la fois il faut aussi laisser
vivre le système c'est laisser les gens
avoir des idées etc et toute la
difficulté elle est de réguler cela
étant ou je te rejoins quand même au
final assez largement c'est
particulièrement sur le monde des
diagnostiqueurs etc et sur le monde des
entreprises des artisans sur ces sujets
énergétiques aujourd'hui oui l'enjeu il
est plutôt d'aller vers de la
standardisation de la formation
formation des entreprises et et j'avoue
que c'est un des points qui nous nous
soucient aussi beaucoup c'est qu'on met
beaucoup d'argent sur ces questions
d'efficacité énergétique donc très
objectifivement on peut se poser des
questions sur un certain nombre
d'entreprises de démarches donc là je
pense qu'on a tous collectivement un
très gros travail à faire notamment
vraiment de formation des acteurs tout
simplement
enfin c'est ta vie c'est le vôtre du
cette année c'est le mien aussi mais la
Fédération du bâtiment par exemple nous
a dit qu'il y avait aucun problème de
qualification
monsieur le président
très bien allez-y monsieur je vais te
présenter c'est ça
qui va dans le sens du CSTB on avait
accompagné une commune pour la
rénovation d'une école et ils avaient eu
ils étaient partis sur l'idée
d'isolation d'isolé par l'extérieur avec
du polystyrène et le Budo d'étude
thermique a montré que en utilisant du
polystyrène ils allaient dégager
beaucoup plus de CO2 parce que le
polystyrène vient du pétrole que ce
qu'ils étaient censé économiser donc
voilà donc c'est c'est vrai que c'est
c'est un vrai sujet et c'est la limite
pour moi d'un standardisation parce que
en fait à chaque projet il y a une
solution différente et à chaque climat
il y a une solution différente c'est pas
la même solution qu'on doit appliquer à
Pau et puis à Lille donc pour prendre
deux extrêmes et c'est vraiment là que
l'ingénierie locale est extrêmement
importante
est-ce que quelqu'un veut rajouter
quelque chose parce que moi je veux une
question à vous poser
comment parce que ce travail va
déboucher sur un rapport qu'est-ce que
vous auriez à nous dire pour que les
porteurs de projets les collectivités
soient se retourne vers vers vous plus
spontanément que ça n'est le cas
aujourd'hui parce que beaucoup bien sûr
le cerema l'ADEME c'est très connu mais
pour beaucoup le céréma il fait les
études routières et la dame d'un verset
subvention mais je suis persuadé que
tout le monde ne sait pas les autres
missions que vous conduisez les uns et
les autres chacune de vos
responsabilités respectives quels
conseils nous donneriez-vous pour que
ces demandes là se parle plus facilement
et plus plus comment dirais-je
plus directement
je veux bien démarrer dans excusez-moi
dans le sens où
c'est
pour nous ça devient un primordial de
s'assurer que ce que l'on fait est su
quelque part pour être utilisé quand je
vous parlais de la base de données
nationales des bâtiments ce qui est
intéressant aujourd'hui c'est que vous
si vous voulez savoir ce qu'il faut
faire stratégiquement au niveau du parc
vous pouvez avoir accès aux 35,7
millions de logements du parc
résidentiel existant mais vous en tant
que particulier si vous allez à votre
adresse vous allez aussi avoir
l'information et là vous tenez le fil
d'Ariane parce que là je vous amène sur
un site public qui vous dit je suis à
cette adresse là d'ailleurs on l'a
groupé sur le réseau faire là s'il
existe quelque chose que ça vienne du
serima de cube des acteurs de terrain on
peut vous le mettre à disposition à
Sandra vous venez de taper votre adresse
je suis chez vous et là je vous tiens
par la main je pense qu'avec un appui
public qui établit qu'effectivement
c'est un site de confiance là on peut
les prendre par la main en disant ben
effectivement cet outil de vous pouvez
le faire ce conseiller là vous pouvez le
contacter parce que justement il est
dans un réseau que l'on a déjà validé
vous le tenez par la main et ensuite
progressivement s'aperçoit que les gens
mais finalement ils découvrent cet outil
là je le connais pas je l'utilise oui je
peux avancer de tel manière mais on est
chez les gens par l'intermédiaire de
cette base là et nous on croit beaucoup
qu'aujourd'hui il faut attraper les
particuliers d'ailleurs on a fait on a
fait une plateforme gorénov particulier
pour ça les collectivités qui ont
commencé à regarder un parc un peu plus
diffus donc particulier leur parc de de
bâtiments scolaire les bailleurs sociaux
et donc je pense qu'il faut les tenir
par la main tout ce que l'on sait dire
sur chaque typologie il faut les grouper
à l'adresse des gens qui se posent la
question je pour moi c'est aussi simple
que ça et d'ailleurs je pense la même
chose pour les aides au sens général on
voit que les aides aujourd'hui sont sur
le geste mais aujourd'hui on peut mettre
le on peut mettre l'aide à l'adresse je
suis à l'adresse je viens de faire un
audit l'audit préconise une isolation
par l'extérieur et un changement
d'équipement et bien je peux mettre
l'aide sur ce pack là à cette adresse là
j'oserais je dirais même avec cette
occupant là parce qu'aujourd'hui on
pourrait savoir aussi à qui on a affaire
et je pense que là on les tient par la
main c'est aussi simple que ça il faut
amener les outils à un endroit où les
gens n'ont qu'une seule chose à saisir
leur adresse
je vous en prie madame Ledermann
un petit sujet mais si les sénateurs
peuvent nous aider ce serait très bien
c'est c'est en fait au niveau de la
visibilité si on fait un événement
justement si quand on fait des
événements comme par exemple on peut
faire un reportage dans un établissement
scolaire qui a mis en place cubes et qui
a fait des vrais économies d'énergie si
on a un sénateur qui vient on va voir la
presse locale si on a la presse locale
toute la collectivité les collectivités
avoisinantes vont comprendre vont lire
le sujet et ça nous aide énormément
parce que nous on n'a pas les moyens de
faire de la pub à la télé sans arrêt etc
donc en fait là-dessus vous pouvez nous
vous pouvez vraiment nous aider c'est un
petit sujet mais c'est très utile
sur cette question là je crois que ça a
été dit par plusieurs et encore
récemment il faut une ingénierie
territoriale et des gens qui soient très
de nos qui soient très de nos
collectivités
près de nos pré des acteurs de terrain
c'est un sujet je ne vois plus bouger
donc j'espère que
vous m'entendez on vous entend
donc
je voudrais simplement
on a besoin
collectivement mais
de pérenniser une présence de terrain
qui puisse s'inscrire dans la durée qui
puisse être au niveau de ce que sont les
besoins des collectivités je disais tout
à l'heure que on est une douzaine de
conseillers d'énergie partagée sur une
département
travaillant en réseau correctement avec
le Syndicat des énergies j'ai oublié le
sérieux tout à l'heure c'est mal et le
représentant
en travaillant dans synergie
qui peut arriver à faire des choses
assez correctes
là en nous vous en plus
monsieur
ça ne vous ressemble pas de vous arrêter
subitement donc je pense que vous avez
été coupé
je vous en prie
de ce que disait Rémi chabria oui en
fait la question c'est la question aussi
du financement que l'on doit accorder
aux collectivités pour se doter de façon
pérenne de cette de cette ingénierie
territoriale experte qui est
complètement neutre et indépendante et
qui lorsqu'elle est en plein
opérationnalité ne coûte rien aux
collectivités si ce n'est leur soutien
de départ donc c'est vraiment important
et pour souligner aussi un travail
partenariat que l'on fait avec le CAE
notamment en Gironde puisque je suis
conseiller régional de Gironde également
nous travaillons beaucoup à partir d'un
programme européen qui s'appelle
violette sur comment rénover et alliés à
la fois
patrimoine ancien et performance
énergétique donc c'est possible mais
c'est possible aussi parce que nous
sommes sur le terrain à proximité et
concernant les Alecs on a vraiment
besoin d'une pérennité et de donner les
moyens en fait à toutes les
collectivités de se doter de cette ING
ierie dont elles ont besoin pour aller
plus loin
très bien monsieur Bertaud
avec mes excuses Rémi chabrillage j'ai
été coupé mais je vois à l'instant que
ma présidente a magnifiquement pris de
relais donc merci et pardon dans mes
excuses tout excusé monsieur perteau je
vais vous faire la même réponse que
celle que j'ai faite à la délégation au
collectivités du Sénat sur d'autres
sujets d'ailleurs que que les bâtiments
scolaires
il y a 35 ans 40 ans il y avait dans
chaque département des DDE des DDA avec
des gens dont le métier était d'aller
aider les collectivités je suis pas
passéiste mais faut quand même bien
remarquer que ça fonctionnait avec un
tas de défauts voilà et que du jour où
on a supprimé tout ça pour l'instant on
n'a pas encore trouvé par quoi le
remplacer donc en fait moi l'idée elle
est assez simple c'est quand même pas
très très compliqué de recréer ça
quelque part alors pas pas dans les
mêmes formes pas la même échelle mais
entre nous si vous mettez des petites
cellules d'une dizaine de personnes par
exemple exemple rattaché à la NCT
pour ça a priori dans chaque département
parce que moi je suis comme madame je
crois beaucoup à la proximité et bah
vous pouvez du coup avoir des gens qui
peuvent aiguiller les collectivités vers
le bon interlocuteur etc ce que ce que
tu évoqué voilà donc je veux dire
aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est c'est
l'affaire de
en plus c'est pas forcément dans tous
les départements mais bon allez entre
500 et 1000 et TP et est-ce vraiment à
l'échelle des enjeux en matière de
transition écologique d'adaptation au
changement climatique parce que là on
parle de transition mais sujet
d'adaptation vont être assez fort
et est-ce que c'est vraiment énorme à
l'échelle de la France j'en suis pas si
sûr
puisque nos chapitres de la nostalgie
moi aussi j'ai connu
ces entités là et ça fonctionnait quand
même plutôt bien
je n'ai jamais cru pour ceux qui me
concerne
aux qualités qu'on prête aux vertus
qu'on prête à l'anct j'espère être
démenti mais j'observe que les
représentés sur le territoire par le
préfet qui est déjà débordé
et que dans le même temps quand on est
ceinture on dit ce qu'on veut en même
temps les DDT n'ont presque plus
personnel enfin il se trouve que
l'administration déconcentré a été
fortement d'ailleurs sur la Cour des
comptes qu'il le dit fortement pénalisée
déshabiller dans tous les territoires de
France et c'est vraiment dommage je
pense que ça serait vraiment
utile et sachez que les mers en
souffrent j'avais il y a une dizaine de
jours et après je vous donne la parole
j'ai pas oublié monsieur
Perrin la chambre générale d'une
association de maire
au cours de laquelle de nombreux maires
ont fait part de de la souffrance qui
était la leur parce qu'il n'arrivait
plus à trouver le bon interlocuteur pour
le sujet qu'il les préoccupé autant à
fond avant qu'on connaissait le numéro
de téléphone
de la DDT du DDA du responsable du
réseau de gaz du responsable de la ligne
téléphonique chaque morceau de
territoire avait un responsable
identifié et la vie était facile et
progressivement pour notamment RGPP
modernisation action publique 2022
chacun y a appris sa part et pour en
arriver à un territoire quelque peu
quelque peu déshabillé mais il faut
faire avec c'est pour ça que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure Monsieur
Bertrand pardon
le fait qu'on pourrait s'appuyer que sur
sur la préfecture sur le DDT je crains
que il y ait pu de ressources
suffisantes pour aider les communes à
progresser sur ce champ là
monsieur Perrin
sur cette idée c'était elle peut être
aussi pour partie externalisée avec tes
réseaux qu'on représente Adem acte de
manière plus générale les réseaux locaux
aussi qu'on le serema l'iPad et
l'approche blog locale en tout cas en
particulier et par contre si on se
heurte une problématique une sorte de
hiatus dans la proche de continuité de
du service public sur le fait que nos
financements a duré limité je crois que
c'est un des propos liminaires de
l'ADEME c'est aussi un de nos propos en
tant que tel nous sommes sur un
programme acté plus doté de 220 millions
d'euros c'est une bonne somme on en est
satisfait et ça permet de faire pas mal
de choses mais se termine en 2026 donc
du coup on a quand même une durée
d'action qui est limitée lorsqu'on va
ouvrir très concrètement un poste de CEP
ou un poste économe de flux on a un
financement qui va le garantir entre
deux et quatre ans qu'est-ce qui se
passe après c'est de ou quatre ans en
l'occurrence c'est une vraie
problématique et dans l'embauche on le
voit très concrètement c'est à dire que
vous allez avoir une fiche de poste
éventuellement dans un bureau d'études
dans une grande ville en CDI à X
milliers d'euros et de l'autre vous
allez avoir un poste en CDD dans une
collectivité rurale à X - 25% dans une
collectivité et donc on attractivité ces
métiers là on souffre extrêmement
fortement notamment cette qualité de
vision durable donc la question la
durabilité l'action publique dans qui se
peut exprimer par la durée du
financement avec une vision long terme
elle est essentielle surtout sur ces
sujets on est sur mesure
d'investissement on le répète des enjeux
extrêmement forts au niveau territorial
mais des enjeux qui vont pas nous
occuper uniquement sur l'année des
années de crise énergétique dans
laquelle on est aujourd'hui Jean-Pierre
ont aussi l'idée du centre des
ressources vous avez compris qu'on était
volontaires on n'a pas aujourd'hui mais
je pense que vous avez déjà auditionné
la cellule batiscolaire du ministère
d'éducation nationale qui produit des
guides une très grande qualité la
problématique c'est que personne ne les
connais c'est qui là nous on les connaît
en tant qu'expert puisqu'on est dedans
en revanche il y a pas de vitrine qui
permet de les connaître les faire
connaître les porter au niveau du
territoire et cette approche collégiale
l'outil qui a présenté Julien la
dynamique du concours cuve des
ressources qu'on comporte avec le sérum
vous portez directement effectivement
aussi qu'on produit aussi au centre
d'acné de la cellule Battice scol aire
il y a quelque chose à créer en termes
de portail et si vous pouvez être
effectivement l'élément permettant
d'avoir une approche d'ensemble liés à
ce niveau là on vous en serait très
reconnaissant on arrive à travailler
entre nous mais un coup de pouce
pourrait élargir encore le sac des
acteurs que vous avez aujourd'hui en
face de vous et toujours le bienvenu
très bien je veux dire que on a
auditionné certains élus qui n'ont pas
le même point de vue sur la qualité du
guide que vous évoquez
il les connaissent il les connaissent et
qui est arrivé qui est arrivé selon ses
collectivités un peu tard et que c'est
collectivités avaient enclenché la
démarche bien avant
mais bon c'est comme ça on peut pas
plaire à tout le monde
mais chez Bertrand parce que j'ai montré
ce guide à ma présidente ce matin même
Président c'est la mère de
Montceau-les-Mines et qui m'a dit ouais
tu es sympa mais tu vois il fait 250
pages moi jamais je dirais ça voilà
c'est un peu ça c'est un peu ça et du
coup au cinéma on a vachement travaillé
sur des petits guides pour les élus
justement qui soit dans un format
beaucoup plus accessible en fait parce
que
allez-y monsieur
l'expérience nous montre que tous ces
guides rénovation j'ai en tête un guide
rénovation ABC très très bien fait très
bien documenté un super contenu sauf que
quand vous avez fini de le lire vous
avez déjà oublié la page numéro 3 en
tout cas pour ce qui me concerne
aujourd'hui on a quand même des outils
numériques on peut faire des choses
ciblées on peut questionner les gens on
peut garder l'information on peut
envoyer des simulations on peut revenir
et ça c'est encore une fois on nous
prend par la main plus besoin de tout
tout comprendre il y a de l'intelligence
quelque part apporter qui permet à des
gens dont l'ingénierie et plus fragile
de faire je vous donne un exemple sur
les écoquartiers sur les écoquartiers on
a des outils pour compter le carbone
compter le carbone c'est juste vital ici
moi aujourd'hui on peut plus faire
autrement on nous a dit ah bah oui mais
on est toute petite collectivités vont
avoir du mal non compter le carbone
c'est comme compter 2 euros c'est très
simple si vous avez un outil qui vous
prend par la main et qui vous permet de
le faire on va pas tout de suite vous
parler d'analyse de cycle de vie de
compensation de moduler de choses comme
ça c'est très très simple de mettre des
outils dans les mains de gens qui sont
des généralistes et donc dans les
territoires on pense qu'il faut accepter
ça en fait il faut les outils
encore pardon je me permets monsieur le
Président de faire une interaction
encore faut-il qu'il y ait des mains
donc qui est des personnes sur le
territoire susceptible de prendre ses
outils en main et de les mettre en
oeuvre on ne sort pas de ça je crois que
le nœud aujourd'hui les techniques de
réhabilitation elles existent les
c'était alors il y a le jeu je me
permets du coup sur quelque chose qui
était littéraire
de formation et de mise à niveau qui est
quelque chose de continu de régulier on
a il faut toujours en remettre une
couche ça c'est pas c'est pas un
problème mais il y a des compétences
qu'on peut certes améliorer qu'on peut
certes augmenter mais
les outils existent les compétences
existent la capacité humaine
intellectuelle pour faire le travail et
ensuite la complexité la capacité à
accéder à des financements simples et
lisible apparaître quand même
probablement les choses les plus
important
es merci si plus personne ne souhaite
ajouter quoi que ce soit à cette
audition ici
je vous en prie
vous aurez la parole auto 3 couleurs le
vrai
c'est effectivement donc parmi les
recommandations donc je partage la vie
effectivement de la nécessité de mettre
le paquet sur l'ingénierie territoriale
ça on l'a tous dit avec nos différents
nos différents mots aujourd'hui
l'ingénierie existe mais couvre pas tout
et elle est insuffisante donc du coup il
y a sans doute un effort à faire de ce
côté là
au-delà de la coordination de nos
réseaux parce qu'en fait on se coordonne
bien en fait il y a pas de c'est pas
forcément très visible mais en tout cas
c'est en se coordonne donc moi il y a un
enjeu de volumétrie de cette ingénierie
et au-delà de l'ingénierie et de cette
volumétrie il y a un sujet dont on a
quasiment pas parlé c'est la question de
l'emploi parce que même si d'un coup de
Madeleine baguette magique on mettait x
millions sur la table on serait sans
doute bien en peine de trouver des de
trouver des personnes pour pour prendre
ses postes là
donc il y a tout un volet que j'ai
l'impression que les uns et les autres
on n'a pas le temps de faire
malheureusement pas le temps de traiter
donc il faut faire connaître ces métiers
il faut il faut mobiliser les écoles
pour pousser les murs et puis l'urgence
c'est l'adapter les postes c'est à dire
prendre d'autres profils plus éloignés
des thermiciens qu'on recherche tous et
qu'on se pique tous les uns les autres
pour essayer donc de faire de
l'adaptation c'est la prendre d'autres
profils et essayer de d'aider à
travailler sur ces sur ces dans des
équipes qui œuvrent sur la pour la
rénovation donc ça c'est le premier le
premier volet après je partage oui le le
la nécessité de partager des centres de
centre de ressources
qui soient qui soit à gauche ou à droite
ou au centre ou à gauche ça m'est égal
mais au-delà de la vitrine et de la
piste d'atterrissage il y a également la
constitution de ces centres de
ressources qui n'existe pas forcément
toujours donc là ça veut dire qu'il faut
il faut pas il faut qu'il y a il faut
qu'il y ait des personnes qui passent du
temps à identifier les bonnes pratiques
à susciter ces bons retours et en faire
et en faire quelque chose qui soit qui
soit qui fasse pas en rapport de 300
pages quoi donc ça peut faire des
brochures des vidéos des témoignages
alimenter des colloques etc donc il faut
à la fois une vitrine mais il faut
également améliorer le produit donc et
ça ça prend de ça ça prend du temps
on a évacué un peu le sujet également
des travaux et du alors j'ai bien
compris que selon la Fédération il y a
pas de souci moi les directions
régionales de l'ADEME et des CEP m'a dit
qu'en fait le secteur bâtiment est déjà
en surchauffe c'est à dire que si on
multiplie les projets est-ce que
derrière il y aura du répondant que
c'est à dire est-ce qu'il y aura des
bras est-ce qu'il y aura des matériaux
et est-ce que ça sera des coûts des
coûts acceptables parce que j'ai cru
comprendre que tous les démarches
étaient assez
internationalisée et il y a enfin un
autre maillon où je sais enfin il y a
peut-être travaillé c'est le maillon du
portage des travaux c'est-à-dire que les
petites communes il faut de l'ingénierie
pour pour fêter la main
identifier les bouquets de travaux aux
besoins
mais entre ce maillon-là et puis le
maillon de des entreprises qui vont
faire les travaux il y a tout un
cheminement alors dans le cadre du
programme acté il y a eu des
il y a eu des un petit peu de d'huile
qui a été apportée dans ces rouages là
mais à mon avis il y a encore la
question du portage des travaux qui
cette question ça fait sans doute un peu
peur ou encore aux communes voilà donc
j'ai pas la réponse par rapport à cette
question là mais c'est sans doute ou
collectivement on a on a des progrès à
faire je sais qu'il y a des
expérimentations notamment en région
aura avec la SPL Oz aux herbes
correspondances voilà il y a sans doute
des choses à expérimenter et puis à
faire connaître merci monsieur le
président
c'est moi qui vous remercie c'est vrai
que l'une des questions si ce n'est là
question essentielles c'est l'éternel
question du financement vous avez vu que
le fond vert est déjà
épuisé je crois savoir que en tout cas
dans la région qui est la mienne des
moments départements il en est de même
de la DETR et de la DS on est encore
part à la fin de l'année loin s'en fout
et que déjà et c'est un enjeu les
communes voient leurs aides de font en
fonctionnement la dotation de globale de
fonctionnement baissé enfin c'est la
première fois cette année depuis 13 ans
qu'elle ne baisse pas ni de stagne pas
mais elle a augmenté
à peine 300 millions alors que la flash
a eu commandé quelle augmenta de 800
millions mais bon c'est comme ça et donc
par ailleurs il y a une population qui
n'est pas forcément en train de
s'enrichir l'inflation fait son effet
aussi il y a beaucoup d'obstacles mais
on va rester optimiste comme le disait
Frank Sinatra le meilleur reste à venir
merci de votre participation bonne
soirée et sans doute à bientôt où tu
iras en tout cas j'irai avec plaisir
on dira pas au revoir